Herzlich Willkommen zu Alternativlos, die Folge 29. Wir wissen, es hat ein bisschen gedauert seit der letzten Folge und ihr habt schon alle sehnsüchtig gewartet. Und Fefe muss erklären, warum das so war.
Ja, jetzt bin ich schuld. Das war ja klar. Das Problem war, dass ich einen längeren Auslandsaufenthalt in England hatte und da gibt es einfach keine Infrastruktur. Gut, das wusste ich vorher, aber wie schlimm das im Einzelnen ist, das hat mich dann doch kalt erwischt. Da gab es zwar Internet-Hotels, aber das ging überhaupt nicht. Da gab es nicht genug Verfügbarkeit, um da mal eben rauszutelefonieren. Und wir haben dann auch versucht, eine Sendung aufzunehmen. Dann bin ich dann extra nach London gefahren, weil ich mir dachte, London, Weltstadt, Metropole, da gibt es Internet. Aber das Internet in der Lokalität war dann ein WiMAX-Internet und das war noch schlechter als das Hotel-Internet gewesen wäre. Also wir haben es versucht, vorher eine Sendung aufzunehmen. Ich will nicht sagen und konnten die aber nicht verwerten, weil es so schlecht geworden ist. Aber wir probieren es jetzt nochmal und wir freuen uns sehr, heute wieder einen hochkarätigen Gast gewinnen zu können, nämlich Frank Schirrmacher. Hallo.
Genau. Worüber wir heute reden wollen, ist unter anderem die Thesen in Herrn Schirrmachers aktuellen Buch Ego. Da geht es unter anderem um Spieltheorie und um die Frage, wie wir denken und wie unser Denken beeinflusst wird. Wir wollen es mal anfangen, versuchen zu betrachten mit der Frage, wo sind wir denn jetzt eigentlich gerade in dieser Krise und wie sind wir denn eigentlich dahin gekommen? Was hat eigentlich damit der Kalte Krieg und die Spieltheorie zu tun? Wie kommen wir eigentlich aus der Art und Weise zu denken, die uns offensichtlich in dieser Krise nicht mehr weiterhilft, eigentlich raus? Die erste Frage dazu ist ja, wenn wir uns die Politik angucken gerade, dann ist der Wesentlichen redet die ja nicht mehr zum Volk, sondern sie redet ja immer nur noch zu den Märkten. Wie sind wir denn dahin gekommen?
Na ja, also wie wir dahin gekommen sind, das lesen wir im Netz und jeden Tag in der Zeitung. Und selbst diese Lektüre finde ich ja schon, glaube ich, ein Beweis des, sagen wir mal ganz vorsichtig, paradoxalen Systems. Ich kann es mal ganz privat oder persönlich noch mal beschreiben. Wir hatten ja schon mal so ein Gespräch, da haben wir ja schon mal, zwei Jahre schon in der Krise. Also ich schreibe so etwas ja und recherchiere dann oder rede mit Leuten, das ist ja das Tolle, wenn man den Job hat, um sich selber etwas klar zu machen. Und die private oder persönliche Wahrnehmung war, die seit Ausbruch der Lehmann-Krise und all der Folgen war, dass ich permanent mit Leuten zu tun hatten, die über ein System sprachen, mit der Selbstbewusstsein von Naturwissenschaftlern, das in Wahrheit nicht mehr funktionierte. Also so ein Vergleich wäre, man stelle sich vor, Fukushima wäre in die Luft gegangen und die Physiker hätten darüber gestritten, wie überhaupt Physik funktioniert. Ich würde sagen, das ist mal die Grundlage, die wir, auch wenn das bestritten wird, es gibt Ökonomen, die immer noch so tun, als sei alles beim Besten, können wir nicht übersehen, dass hier ein, in Anführungszeichen, wissenschaftliches Denken konterkariert worden ist durch die Krise.
Also diese Verzweiflung der Ökonomen darüber, dass sie eigentlich keine Theorie haben, was eigentlich passiert ist und demzufolge auch nicht mehr, was dann dann später passieren wird, steht ja in krassem Gegensatz zu dem Selbstbewusstsein, mit dem die Forderungen an die Politik stellen, also nach Bailouts und nach Austerity und was da alles so passieren muss. Gerade an diesem Austerity-Beispiel wurde ja neulich klar, wo ein Student mal nachgerechnet hat, die wesentlichen Studien zu diesem Austerity-Ding und festgestellt hat, dass die alle einfach nicht stimmen.
Das war einfach eine Exel-Fehler, dann hat er eine falsche Formel in Exel angetragen. Wobei das durchaus Kontinuität hat. Also wenn man sich anguckt, wie bei bisherigen Wirtschaftskrisen die Antwort war, war das jedes Mal so. Auch bei der Great Depression war das schon so. Auch unter Reagan war das so.
Die hatten auch keine Ahnung.
Die haben noch nie eine Antwort gehabt, die Wirtschaftler. Ich hab neulich mit einem Typen mich unterhalten, der mir das nochmal erklärt hat, dass der Wirtschaftsnobelpreis ja auch nur so fake ist, weil der wird halt nicht von der Nobel...
Ja, von der Schwedischen Reichsbank.
Genau, die Reichsbank hat den ausgelobt, um die Wirtschaftswissenschaften auf eine Stufe mit den Naturwissenschaften zu heben. Und so ist das eigentlich generell. Das wird mein Eindruck inzwischen, dass bei den Wirtschaftswissenschaften eigentlich da eher so die Dogmen vertreten werden, als dass da jemand tatsächlich sich um die Wahrheitsfindung bemüht.
Oder man kann sagen, und das ist ja etwas, was wir als Nichtökonomen meistens gar nicht so mitbekommen, dass hier, ich würde die auch, tun wir ja auch nicht übereinkommen, alle scheren, aber die in Anführungszeichen Renegaten werden in der Wirtschaftswissenschaft ausgegrenzt, wie in einem religiösen System des Mittelalters. Also das sind Leute, das geht ja auch über Schulbildung. Wer kriegt Lehrstühle, wer publiziert wo, wie muss man publizieren? Das ist deshalb so ärgerlich, weil viele Wissenschaftssoziologen, Germanisten, wer auch immer, täuschen sich permanent. Nur es ist deshalb so ärgerlich, wenn es als positive Wissenschaft verkauft wird, die uns Handlungsanweisungen gibt oder wirkliche radikale Interpretationen oder triftige Interpretationen. Wir dürfen nicht vergessen, das war ja die die Bemerkung, die Frank Rieger gerade machte, wir sehen jetzt ja den Preis. Also der Preis ist jetzt vielleicht noch nicht, dass wir jetzt kein Geld mehr haben oder so, aber der Preis ist eben die öffentliche Kommunikation.
Außer die in Zypern, also das ist ja so weit weg nicht.
Das stimmt, ja. Das stimmt, das stimmt. Aber ich würde jetzt mal unter der Perspektive unserer, die Deutschen haben ja einen besonderen Blick auf die Krise, die sie noch im Augenblick wie ein Zuschauersport wahrnehmen. Aber dennoch wird ja schon ein Preis gezahlt. Also wir werden nachher noch über den ökonomischen Preis reden, aber der erste ist ja wirklich der öffentliche Kommunikation. Also die ganz einfache Frage, die sich glaube ich jeder stellen muss und vor allen Dingen auch Journalisten stellen müssen. Wenn Schäuble wie vor vier Wochen oder sechs Wochen verkündet, die Euro-Krise ist im Grunde vorbei. Für wen ist das gesagt? Ist das gesagt für die Deutschen, für Europa, für die Bevölkerung, all dieser Staaten für weder für den Wahlkampf oder für Märkte? Was bedeutet das noch? Er selbst würde wahrscheinlich sagen, selbst wenn es nicht stimmt, ist es doch ein psychologisches Faktum, das als psychologisches Faktum wiederum eine Realität hat. Und das ist glaube ich die Situation, in der wir jetzt sind.
Das heißt, wir aus der Sicht von Herrn Schäuble sind wir also bei, das Bewusstsein bestimmt die Materie.
Ja, nicht nur. So lesen ja mittlerweile sehr viele Leute Märkte. Und so hat der Roboter, der unlängst einen Flash-Crash ausgelöst hat, ja auch Nachrichten gelesen. Das war zwar eine angebliche Realität, dass bei Obama eine Bombe losgegangen sein soll.
Was über den gehackten Twitter-Accord von Epi gelaufen ist.
Aber der hat ja sofort sozusagen Schlussforderungen auf die gesamtkollektive Psyche gezogen. Also das ist ja nicht so überraschend. Die Frage ist nur, ob uns das in einer Demokratie mit all den Begleiterscheinungen, die das doch hatte, ich sage hier ein Bundesverfassungsgericht und so, ob nicht dieser Preis ein wenig ein bisschen hoch wird, weil wir gar nicht mehr wissen, woran wir sind.
Also die Frage ist ja, diese Kommunikation der Politik mit den Märkten, die scheint ja gewissen Gesetzmäßigkeiten zu folgen. Ihre Theorie ist ja, dass die sich in einem spieltheoretischen Game befinden.
Also eigentlich ist das keine Theorie. Das kann man ja nachlesen. Und das ist ja auch der Punkt, warum es mich dann so interessierte. Ich kann doch nur feststellen, es wird nicht mehr ums platt zu sagen linear diskutiert, sondern es wird um die Ecke, zehnfach um die Ecke. Jetzt sagen viele Leute, das hat es immer gegeben. Wenn man aber dann sieht, dass beispielsweise die Bank of America, Mary Lynch bei der Bank of America, vor ich glaube zwei Jahren, eine Analyse der Euro-Krise abgeliefert hat, die es öffentlich näher die gesamte Euro-Krise spieltheoretisch modelliert wird. Und das heißt, all das, von dem wir dauernd reden, wir machen das alles, weil wir Europa kooperativ irgendwann stärken wollen, das ist doch der Widerspruch, in dem wir gerade leben. Das wird nicht etwa nur negiert, das gibt es da gar nicht. Sondern da wird einfach, das wird ganz platt gesagt, die What's Rejolt hat es ja auch gehabt, auch mit Spieltheorie, gehen sie vom Schlimmsten aus, jeder denkt nur an sich. Dann werden die einzelnen Staaten modelliert und dann wird gesagt, es sagt uns ja das Nash-Equilibrium, es gibt eine Lösung, die wird von egoistischen Agenten sehr gerne benutzt, selbst wenn das Ergebnis nicht das optimale Ergebnis für alle ist, sondern für den einzelnen Spieler. Also der gibt dann was Preis, was sozusagen für alle besser wäre, nämlich für das Kollektiv. Und darum sagen sie, gehen sie davon aus, dass Italien der Knackpunkt wird oder nehmen sie William Blair, auch eine Investmentbank, die hat den Investoren richtig die Schritte erläutert, wie man mit Spieltheorie die Euro-Krise verstehen kann. Und die Lautet, die Unter-Schicht dieser Botschaft lautet immer, vielleicht finden das ja Leute mittlerweile auch schon ganz normal, glaubt kein Wort von dem, was die Politiker sagen, glaubt nichts von dem, was ihr liest und hört im Hintergrund, wenn ihr da echt investieren wollt und Geschäfte machen wollt oder keine Verluste erleiden wollt, denkt einfach nur daran, jeder handelt nur egoistisch in seinem absoluten Interesse, um das mal verkürzt zu sagen. Und dann stellt sich ja die Frage, ob solche Deutungen, sage ich mal, nicht die Wirklichkeit auch wiederum verändern. Das ist eine der vielen Fragen, die wir zu stellen haben. Also es ist keine von aus dem Himmel geholte Theorie, die ich hier bemühe, sondern es ist State of the Art. Das ist eine der Interpretationen der Euro-Krise, die auch sehr gut erklärt, wieso dann die Politiker wiederum so reden, wie sie reden, so dass ich heute gar nicht mehr sicher wäre, ob zum Beispiel das, was wir das letzte Mal im Gespräch haben, dieser Kampf um das Plebiszie in Griechenland, ob das nicht auch schon wieder ein Spiel war. Also soweit ist es schon. Und das hat nichts mit Paranoia oder Verschwörungstheorie zu tun, sondern es ist ja nur die Beschreibung eines objektiv nicht mehr verständlichen Prozesses.
Jetzt müssen wir mal ein bisschen die Grundlagen erläutern.
Genau, vielleicht sollen wir erstmal so ein bisschen die Grundlagen der Spieltheorie erklären. Und die wurden ja im Kalten Krieg gelegt. Einer der Mathematiker, die da grundlegende Arbeit gelästet haben, wäre der Herr Nesch. Ich weiß nicht, einige werden wahrscheinlich diesen Film kennen, A Beautiful Mind, der ihn beschreibt. Und was man vielleicht auch eingangs dazu sagen muss, ist, dass der darüber wahnsinnig geworden ist. Oder ist schon wahr. Beziehungsweise dann auch eine ganze Weile gebraucht hat, bis er irgendwie als nicht mehr als so wahnsinnig galt und wieder rausgelassen wurde.
Naja, die Art des Wahnsinns ist auch noch spannend. Ich weiß, der ist ja paranoid, eine Warnvorstellung hat der gehabt. Das heißt, die Grundlagen seiner Theorie, dass alle aus Eigennutzen handeln und ihnen eigentlich belügen und was anderes wollen, hintenrum, das ist ja genau paranoia. Also das ist schon, man könnte quasi hier eine Verbindung sehen an der Stelle. Soweit wollen wir jetzt nicht gehen, aber der Nash hat tatsächlich wahnenberechtende Sachen.
Ich denke, wir können schon soweit gehen. Also lass uns mal den Kern des Nash-Equilibriums und der Spieltheorie erklären.
Ja, wir sagen erstmal Spieltheorie, was das überhaupt ist. Also Spieltheorie ist das wissenschaftliche Fundament der Frage, wie man sich damit beschäftigt, wie zum Beispiel ein Computer Schach spielen soll. Ja, also wenn der Computer, ich schreibe jetzt ein Programm und das soll Schach spielen gegen mich, das hat also ein Widersacher dieses Spiel und kämpft nicht nur bei Tetris oder so was gegen Zufallszahlengenerator oder sowas wie Sudoku lösen, wo es keinen Widersacher gibt. Das gibt es auch, das ist aber nicht Spieltheorie, das ist die Entscheidungstheorie. Spieltheorie ist davon der Unterbereich, in dem es darum geht, dass man einen Widersacher hat und den modelliert man so, dass man sagt, der hält sich an die Regeln, aber es geht ihm darum zu gewinnen. Also der handelt aus Eigennutz, der möchte gern gewinnen und das nutze ich, um vorherzusagen, was er gleich tun wird. Das Nash-Equilibrium, da handelt es jetzt um ein spezielles Problem in der Spieltheorie. Na ja, das erklär du mal.
Genau, also das klassische Szenario der Spieltheorie ist das The Prisoner's Dilemma, was davon ausgeht, dass man hat zwei Gefangene und stellt die vor eine Situation, in der sie entweder nichts sagen können, gestehen können oder den anderen beschuldigen können. Wenn beide nichts sagen, dann gehen beide einfach nach Hause. Also keiner von denen kommt in den Knast. Wenn einer den anderen beschuldigt, dann geht er selber raus. Und wenn beide sich gegenseitig beschuldigen, dann kriegen sie die Hälfte der Strafe. Das war so das klassische Setup.
Und ganz wichtig, sie können nicht miteinander reden.
Genau, das klassische Prisoner's Dilemma. Es findet halt einmal statt. Und sie können nicht miteinander kommunizieren. Und natürlich ist die mathematisch optimale Lösung, ist halt den Verrat zu wählen, also den anderen zu bezüchtigen. Entweder in der Hoffnung, dass der einen selbst nicht bezüchtigt, dann geht man vor free nach Hause. Oder selbst wenn der andere einen bezüchtigt, dann kriegt man eben nur die Hälfte vom Knast, als wenn man gesteht. Das ist einer der simpelsten heruntergekochten Fälle davon. Daraus resultiert eben die mathematische Einsicht, das Egoismus, also nur an sich selbst zu denken und also nicht altruistisch zu handeln, indem man sagt, okay, ich vertraue gerade mal drauf, dass der andere mich nicht in die Pfanne hauen will und sage halt mal nichts oder beschuldige ihn halt nicht. Dass das eine mathematisch schlechtere Lösung wäre, weil sie im Schnitt, wenn man es über viele Iterationen betrachtet, die Wahrscheinlichkeit größer ist, dass man viel länger in den Knast geht. Und darauf aufbauend gibt es dann halt diesen gesamten Zweig der Strategieentwicklung, die im Kalten Krieg quasi die Grundlage für Strategiebildung war und dementsprechend auch eine große Menge an Funding und Erweiterung und Verzweigerung erfahren hat.
Wir sollten vielleicht sagen, das ist jetzt deswegen so wichtig gewesen, was der Nash gemacht hat, weil er den Sprung in, ich will nicht sagen die Realität, aber zumindest in ein Problem aus der Realität von der Mathematik aus geschafft hat. Er hat es geschafft, dass wir sagen können, mit mathematischen Mitteln können wir diese Situationen bewerten.
Modellieren.
Modellieren, ja, wir können sie modellieren und wir können, wenn wir in der Situation sind, sie bewerten und zu einem Ergebnis kommen. Das heißt, wir können jetzt uns unabhängig machen davon, dass irgendein Typ am Knopf sitzt und die Entscheidung trifft, sondern wir können es rationalisieren. Wir können es so machen, dass wir da Regeln aufstellen und dass wir uns vorher überlegen, in welchem Fall wir was tun wollen und dass wir uns auch sicher sein können, wenn unser Modell korrekt ist natürlich, dass die Antwort auch tatsächlich die optimale ist an der Stelle. Also das war im Grunde der wesentliche Teil, warum das im Kalten Krieg angewendet wurde.
Vielleicht noch ein, zwei Satze zur Geschichte und dann auch gleich etwas, weil ja natürlich jetzt gleich der eine oder andere Hörer sofort rufen wird, Kooperation, kooperative Modelle gibt es auch und so weiter. Zunächst mal, was man sich gar nicht heute mehr vorstellen kann, ist, dass, als das entstand ja eigentlich schon im zweiten Weltkrieg in England, die Urgeschichte sozusagen, als das so durchsickerte, es war ja hoch geheim, kann man sich den Enthusiasmus, die Begeisterung, die Teile der Öffentlichkeit, übrigens auch der Boulevardpresse in den 50er Jahren ergriff, gar nicht vorstellen. Man muss sich vorstellen, eines der ersten Bücher, die darüber als wichtigste vielleicht darüber erschienen ist, hatte im Untertitel Strategien für Poker, Business und Krieg. In einem sozusagen, alles eins. Und dort wird berichtet, ich zitiere das ja, wie der den einen der Luftwaffenoffiziere, die sich damit befassen, also im Pentagon besucht, muss so gewesen sein, schätze ich jetzt mal 49, 50. Und er zu ihm sagt, und das war auch wirklich die Lesart, was wir hier machen, ist so wie das neue Manhattan-Projekt. Wir bauen eine neue Waffe. Wir sind sehr aufgeregt und glauben, es wird genauso wichtig wie das Manhattan-Projekt. Zeitsprung 90er Jahre des 20. Jahrhunderts, als die Quants, die Labor verlassen und die Physiker, also und zur Wall Street gehen, zitiere ich auch, gibt es viele, viele Quellen dafür, sagen die, das ist unser neues Manhattan-Projekt. Das ist genauso wichtig wie das zweite Manhattan-Projekt. Vier, fünf Jahre später kommt Warren Buffett und spricht von Massenvernichtungswaffen auf Finanzmärkten. Das nur mal um eine Kontinuitätskette, auch nur der Metaphern zu sehen. Ein Hinweis zur Kooperation, weil das ja immer wieder kommt und das steht ja auch, das sagen wir ja auch alle. Die Spieltheorie hat, die ist ein interessantes, neben der historischen Entwicklung zu sehen. Irgendwann kamen ja dann tatsächlich Bewegungen in die Weltmächte. Und tatsächlich sah man auch, dass das rein egoistische Modell Grenzen hatte. Die Militärs setzten auch viel stärker auf Simulation als auf die Spieltheorie. Und dann kam eben die Idee, man kann das auch kooperativ modellieren. Berühmtes Beispiel Axel Roth, der also alles über Computer gelaufen, Computer gegeneinander antreten ließ und die hatten eine Prämisse. Erstens, am Anfang, beim ersten Schachzug ist der Spielzug, ist der Spieler kooperativ und danach handelt er nur noch nach Tit-for-tat, also wie du mir, so ich dir. Und das zeigte sich, ah, das funktioniert. Das Problem ist nur, diese immer wieder erwähnten kooperativen Modelle funktionieren halt nur in Wiederholungsspielen und nicht in Einmalaktionen und auch nicht in anonymen Einmalaktionen, wie sie zum Beispiel automatisierte Finanzmärkte kennzeichnen.
Um es mal präzise zu formulieren, da gibt es halt dieses Modell, das ist ja noch ein Iterative Prisoner's Dilemma. Man wiederholt das Spiel mehrere Male und dann gibt es halt verschiedene Parameter, wenn sich die Softwareagenten erkennen können und sich erinnern können, wie der andere beim letzten Mal gehandelt hat. Dann gibt es tatsächlich eine kooperative Lösung. Der Herr Freeman Dyson hatte auch ein Papier letzten Mai publiziert.
Dass kein Mensch versteht, wie ich höre, aber die dies annähernd verstehen, sagen, es sei genial.
Er ist ziemlich gut, er hat tatsächlich einen Beweis dafür gefunden, dass im Attorative Prisoners Dilemma, also in diesem wiederholten Spiel, tatsächlich eine kooperative Lösung, die optimale Lösung ist.
Sein Sohn gab es mir kurz bevor es erschien und sagte, er vermutet dafür gibt es bald den Nobelpreis. Schauen wir mal. Darf ich noch zu Fefes Bemerkung mit dem Schachspiel etwas sagen? Es geht hier um ein Versuch zu verstehen unsere Gegenwart. Ich glaube, selbst wenn es jetzt nicht wie 1 und 1 und 2 aufgeht, sind sehr wichtig zu sehen, mit welchen Metaphern wir operieren. Und warum es so wichtig ist, das hat man jetzt ja schon erkannt, wieso das natürlich erst eine Relevanz bekommt, wirklich in Finanzmärkten, die von Maschinen gesteuert werden bzw. wo die Menschen immer mehr verschwinden, die sich zum Teil seit Generationen kannten. Und das Spiel, das hat ja dieser Journalist schon Ende der 40er Jahre richtig erkannt. Poker ist natürlich ein anderes als Schach. Das ist, diese Leute erwähne ich, die in dem 50er-Jahr damit schon sich dazu äußerten, die Kultur des verdeckten Spiels. Bei Poker kenne ich die Karten des anderen nicht. Das heißt, ich muss davon ausgehen, dass da ich die Karten nicht kenne, der mir ständig falsche Signale sendet. Dann sind wir auf der Ebene des Bluffs, auf der Ebene einer Kommunikation, die etwas völlig anderes suggeriert, um ihr Ziel zu erreichen. Damit sind wir wieder bei der Eingangsfrage, dieser Euro-Krise und der politischen Kommunikation heute, die wie ich glaube, eine Kommunikation des Bluffs ist. Diese Kultur des verdeckten Spiels, von denen einer sagte ganz hellsichtig in den 50er Jahren, wenn wir diese Kultur schaffen, werden wir irre psychische Probleme schaffen in einer Gesellschaft, weil nichts mehr das bedeutet, was es ist, weil die Leute ständig allen misstrauen müssen. Und partiell zumindest scheint das ja auch da geworden. Denken Sie an Solar Lottery. Erschienen glaube ich 55, 56, wo ja schon eine Gesellschaft vorausgesehen hat. Genau, Philipp Kittig.
Das ist tatsächlich eines der, müssen wir noch an die Buchempfehlungen tun, Philipp Kittig, Solar Lottery ist ein großartiges Buch.
Schon unglaublich, wenn man es heute liest. Da steht zum Beispiel auch drin, im Sinne dieser Risiko, die Gesellschaft konnte nur noch glauben, dass sie eine Gesellschaft ist, die Risiken ständig berechnen muss, weil sie mit ihnen nicht mehr umgehen konnte.
Genau, da sind wir ja sozusagen an dem interessanten Punkt. Wenn wir uns jetzt mal die Historie angucken, der Spieltheorie im Kalten Krieg, war es der Versuch, diesen Simulationen irgendeiner Art von mathematisches Unterfutter zu geben. Also eine mathematische Annahme darüber treffen zu können, wie sich der Gegner bewegen würde. Und eines der am meisten übersehenden Details gerade in der Strategie im Kalten Krieg ist ja, dass die Amerikaner ja Pokerspieler waren und die Russen Schachspieler. Und dementsprechend sind auch die Strategien, während die Amerikaner häufig mit Blöff agiert haben oder mit dem Versuch, sich irgendwie durchzumogeln, haben die Russen ja, wie sie es im Schachspiel gewohnt sind, diese noch einen Junk-Tims erfunden. Also dass sie völlig entgegengesetzte, völlig verlagerte Politikbereiche miteinander verknüpft haben. Also dass sie gesagt haben, uns stören eure nuklearen Kurzstrakten-Raketen in der Türkei. Also stellen wir euch mal welche in Kuba vor die Tür, völlig andere Ecke der Welt. Und am Ende, also wenn man sich anguckt, was das Outcome davon war, haben sie ja gewonnen. Die Amerikaner haben ihre Raketen abgezogen am Ende der Kuba-Krise. Also es sieht ja immer so aus, als hätte Khrushchov die Kuba-Krise völlig versemmelt. Aber was irgendwie das strategische Outcome angeht, war das ein Gewinn für die Russen, weil sie halt einfach die Raketen an ihrer Südflanke wegbekommen. Und diese unterschiedliche Art des Herangehens hat natürlich mit der Sozialisierung zu tun. Die Amerikaner spielen Poker, die Russen spielen Schach.
Vielleicht noch eine Burempfehlung auch hier, die ich immer wieder ein großartiger Denker finde ich. Wenn man davon ausgeht, dass in den 50er, 60er, 70er Jahren eine Maschine gebaut wurde und zwar nicht der Computer. Der Computer war dann kongenial dazu. Das war eine Maschine des Denkens, die zunächst strategische Bedeutung hat. Man hat dazu hilfete, kein deutlich von Ökonomen, Militärs an erster Stelle. Dann muss man den, der das überhaupt alles auf den Begriff gebracht hat, erwähnen, Philipp Mirowski, Machine Dreams. Das ist eben einer dieser Ökonomen, der in seiner Branche sehr an den Rand gedrängt worden ist. Von dem jetzt im Juni ein neues Buch kommt, auch zur Krise insgesamt, zur Lehman-Krise. Der hat das mit dem Gang in die Archive und so weiter unglaublich suggestiv nach erzählt. Viele haben das bestritten, viele haben sich dagegen gewehrt. Aber als dann später Bücher kamen, auch zur Spieltheorie, die auf ihm fußten, wurde doch klar, wie unglaublich relevant das ist.
Wir müssen glaube ich nochmal ein bisschen diese Geschichte erzählen, die eigentlich vom Kalten Krieg zu den Börsen und den 90ern kam. Also für mich wichtig ist halt nochmal auch zu verstehen, diese Geistesatmosphäre in den 50er und 60er Jahren, als die Spieltheorie tatsächlich zum Fundament der Politik wurde. Also sollten wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen dran erinnern, was da eigentlich alles passiert ist. Wo die Amerikaner, weil sie keinen strategischen Ausweg aus diesem gegenseitigen Festgefahren sein wussten.
Die Atombombe, das muss man auch nochmal erzählen, was das eigentlich war. Die Atombombe, wir kennen die, wir sind damit ja groß geworden.
Aber damals war die neu.
Ja, eine Waffe, die, wo immer einer noch eine hatte, die anderen vernichten kann.
Ja, dieses Prinzip der gegenseitigen Abschreckung damals war ja eine quasi nicht bewusste Erfindung, sondern die ist ja tatsächlich entstanden. Und dann wurden Strategien daraus entwickelt. Also man kam ja aus dem Zweiten Weltkrieg, also aus der Logik von, nie wieder wollte man in einen Grabenkrieg verwickelt werden. Also wenn man sich so die Militärstrategie des Zweiten Weltkriegs anguckt, dann waren alle Seiten immer bestrebt, in Bewegung zu bleiben. Also niemand wollte wieder in diese festgefahrene Graben-Situation des ersten Weltkriegs, also insbesondere die deutschen Generäle, nicht aber auch die sowjetischen, nicht. Alle wollten immer unbedingt einen Krieg der Bewegung haben, also einen, wo sie Optionen haben, wo sie sich bewegen können, wo sie ausweichen können. Und nicht in diesen endlosen Materialschlachten enden. Und plötzlich ist man aber auf der geostrategischen Ebene genau da wieder gelandet.
Es gab ja mehrere, wir verkürzen hier ja natürlich, aber die erste Phase war ja wirklich die. Der Atombombe ist neu. Und John von Neumann und andere, vor allen Dingen auch Hermann Kahn, waren ja durchaus der Meinung, ja jetzt ist die Antwort schnell, die Bombe auf die Sowjetunion werfen. Dann sind wir wenigstens der erste. Das war ungefähr die Phase der 50er Jahre. Da gibt es ja noch und noch eben bis hin zu Dr. Seltsam. Ja und Kahn geht da ja im thermonuklearen Krieg. Ist ja heute gar nicht mal vorstellbar, dass er da ganze Säle füllte mit Reden darüber, dass es für Amerika dann zwar schon schlimm ist, wenn New York und Washington untergeht, aber es immer noch ganz viele andere Städte gibt, die dann übrig bleiben und so weiter.
Also Mao hat ja eine Zeit lang tatsächlich die Strategie gefahren, zu sagen, wir sind die Einzigen, die von der Amatomkrieg profitieren können, weil wir sind halt genug. So von uns ist noch die Hälfte übrig nach dem Amatomkrieg von den anderen nicht.
Und dann kam die zweite Phase und das ist eben die, wo die Spieltheorie sehr relevant wurde. Die Militärs nahmen sie viel ernster damals als Theokonomen und das war in der Tat dieses, okay, wir kommen da nicht mehr raus. Wie können wir jetzt rational mit den Russen, denen wir nicht glauben, oder die Russen, wie können wir mit denen umgehen? Und dann kommen sie auf das, was sie gerade sagen, Gleichgewicht des Schreckens. Immer die Unterstellung, nichts stimmt. Er hat aber auch kein Interesse, die eine Seite hat kein Interesse, selber unterzugehen. Das ging ja ganz real. Das ging um die Frage, welche SS20 man wohin stellt. Das wurde ja richtig mathematisch modelliert. Und bei der Frage dieses, ihr könnt kein Interesse haben, uns zu vernichten, weil ihr dann selber untergeht, will ich jetzt nur mal einen kleinen Hinweis geben. Das ist einen dann schon wundert, wenn man in den Lehmann Papieren liest. Wir haben es ja alle erlebt. Uns kann gar nichts passieren, weil wenn wir untergehen, reißen wir das ganze System mit in Abgrund. Also dieses Prinzip hoch aufgerüsteter Systeme, die so systemrelevant sind, darum eben auch die Begriffe Kernschmelze und all das, was wir da gehört haben, dass sie den Untergang der anderen Seite, in Anführungszeichen der Zivilgesellschaft, was auch immer bedingt, haben wir, wie ich finde, eben auch seit der Lehmann-Krise erlebt.
Die spannende Frage ist ja, diese Rückschau auf den Kalten Krieg, die verklärt sich ja zunehmend. Wenn man so zurückguckt, dann...
Darf ich noch kurz eine andere Kontinuität erwähnen, die ich an der Stelle wichtig finde. Und zwar gab es ja im Kalten Krieg auch Sperrverträge, dass man keine neuen Atomwaffentests durchführt. Und unter anderem gab es eben ein Vertrag, in dem drin stand, dass es jede Seite wurde zugestanden, eine Raketenabwehr zu haben für ihre Hauptstadt und für einen anderen Punkt, wenn ich mich richtig entsinne.
Für einen Missile Feud, ja.
Also damit sie noch eine Rückschlagsfähigkeit aufrechterhalten können zur Drohung. Und ansonsten aber keine. Und dann kommt Reagan und sagt, wir bauen jetzt aber SDI. Und er wusste natürlich, dass es nicht geht. Der hat ja keine blöden Berater gehabt. Der selbst war vielleicht nicht der Hellste, aber an der Stelle muss ihm das völlig klar gewesen sein, dass es nicht realistisch ist. Aber darum ging es nicht. Der hat die Regeln absichtlich verletzt, um sich dadurch im Spiel ein Vorteil zu verschaffen. Und diese Einsicht haben wir jetzt auch bei den systemrelevanten Banken, die irgendwann sagen, es lohnt sich aus meiner Sicht, Profit daraus zu schlagen, dass ich gegen das System spiele. Zum Beispiel, wenn jetzt jemand wie Lehmann kommt und gegen die Hypotheken wettet, die sie selbst verkauft haben, weil sie wissen, dass die nix wert sind. Aber sie verscheuern sie auf der einen Seite an Kunden und sagen denen, hör mal, das sind tolle Hypotheken. Auf der anderen Seite wetten sie aber darauf, dass die Preise runtergehen werden davon. Das macht ja rational keinen Sinn, bis man eben sich überlegt, dass das im Kalten Krieg genauso lief. Dass die irgendwann gesehen haben, die ultimative Vernichtungswaffe, die wir hier haben, die können wir eigentlich gar nicht einsetzen. Das heißt, die ultimative Drohung, die wir geglaubt haben zu haben, haben wir gar nicht. Im Grunde haben wir überhaupt nichts, mit dem wir drohen können. Und auf der Gegenseite sieht es genauso aus. Die können uns auch nicht angreifen, weil sie wissen, dass wir sonst zurück vernichten. Und diese Idee, dass ich mich gegen das System, was mich selbst nähert und einem Leben hält, wenden kann, um daraus kurzfristigen Profit zu ziehen, weil das System auch andere am Leben erhält und die schon dafür sorgen werden, dass das System lebt. Das finde ich eine großartige Kontinuität zwischen dem Kalten Krieg und den Banken.
Aragon Star Wars, da hat Paul Edwards sehr toll in seinem Buch Closed Worlds geschrieben. Hätte, wie Fefe gerade sagte, nie funktioniert. Und das ist doch besonders interessant. Wir gehen ja im Kalten Krieg in eine Phase der totalen Virtualisierung. Auch die Atombombe ist letztlich virtuell, denn sie wird ja zum Glück nicht eingesetzt.
Und auch nicht getestet, sie wird nur simuliert.
Genau, sie wird nur simuliert. Das heißt, und dieses Virtuelle, da gehen die Meinungen auseinander, wie sehr Star Wars die Untergangsglass-Wette nun beschleunigt hat. Ich empfehle nur mal, rein nur sprachlich, die Metaphorik bei dem Raketenschutzschirm von Reagan zu vergleichen mit der Metaphorik beim Rettungsschutzschirm ESM. In der ist genau das gleiche Virtuelle eine Annahme. Wir wissen ja, wenn es wirklich ernst würde, würde das ja nicht funktionieren. Das Geld gibt es ja gar nicht. Aber diese Systeme gab es auch nicht. Ich finde, es kann man, man kann doch gar nicht übersehen. Und ich glaube, das ist ein Phänomen dieser Virtualisierung, in der wir uns befinden. Die Identitäten zwischen diesen beiden Vorgängen, also dem Kalten Krieg auf der einen Seite und einem jetzt ständig, das erleben wir ja jeden Tag, lesen wir das doch in den Nachrichten. Es ist ständig Chicken Game. Es ist ständig zwei Autos rasen aufeinander zu. Wer weicht als Erster aus? Es ist ständig dieses an der Mauer stehen und einer hat diese Atto Europa bricht auseinander, scheiterte Euro, there is no alternative. Das sind ja alles die Sätze, die wir gehört haben. Und jetzt kommt eben dieser Krise, die Idee, die ja auch erstmal funktioniert hat, eines Rettungsschirms gegen diese thermonuklearen Angriffe aus der Finanzwelt.
Wobei, da kann man auch dagegenhalten, dass das Geld, was wir haben, eh schon immer virtuell war. Insofern ist es, dass der Rettungsschirm jetzt virtuell ist, finde ich jetzt keinen großen Schritt mehr.
Naja, ich finde den schon interessant aus dem einfachen Grunde.
Die Rhetorik ist hochspannend.
Genau, ich meine, die SDI war ja nicht wirkungslos.
Genau das ist es ja.
Die SDI, zum einen haben die Milliarden und Abermilliarden da reingeheizt in die Forschung. Und zum anderen haben die Auswirkungen, dass die Sowjetunion wusste, sie können da einfach nicht mehr mithalten. Also, dass es halt einfach nicht mehr geht. Da gab es in so einem kurzen Moment, der ist mittlerweile fast vergessen, wo die sozialistischen Länder, insbesondere die DDR, an asymmetrischen Antworten auf SDI gearbeitet haben. Also, die haben dann halt zum Beispiel solche Sachen, die sich überlegen, wie einen Orbit zu verseuchen, indem man mit einer relativ großen Rakete, mit einer relativ kleinen Payload, in einem Orbit, also der normalen Rotationsrichtung des Orbits, entgegengesetzt einen Orbit schießt und die aus kleinen Keramikteilen bestehen lässt, die da halt einfach als Wolke lang fliegen und diesen gesamten Orbit abräumen. Also sozusagen so eine Strategie des verbrannten Orbits quasi.
Die Chinesen haben das ja mal kurz angetestet.
Um die entsprechenden SDI-Waffen da abzuräumen. Und das haben die nie gebaut und auch nie wirklich getestet, sondern die haben halt einfach nur laut darüber geredet. Und zwar richtig in der Presse so. Also so mit so, uff, übrigens dann würden wir ja mal hier so. Genau, also diese Kommunikationsstrategien sind ja auch vollständig vergleichbar. Also dass die Banken halt gesagt haben so, naja, wenn ihr uns zu doll reguliert, dann weich nur halt in die Dark Pools aus.
Ja, genau, oder ich hab das ja nur mal aus der FAZ und ich glaube, der Neuzurche hat zusammengefasst, die Rhetorik bei diesen Gipfeln, da wird von Abwurfzonen gesprochen, da werden diese gesamten, ja, ja, das hab ich alles zitiert, hier wird die gesamte Metaphorologie benutzt und bis in die Details. Zum Beispiel, wenn so eine Sitzung zu Ende ist, ist alles entscheidend, welche Regierung, also da gibt es dann 20 Pressekonferenzen zum Beispiel, ja, der, der Staaten, welcher Regierungschef ist als Ernster vor der Presse? Und das haben wir jetzt ja mehrfach erlebt. Das sind ja auch wieder diese Spiele. Die Spiele sind ja nicht nur zwischen Finanzmärkten und, sondern sie haben zu einem insgesamt, ich würde ja sagen, durch solche und dieses Systems geführt, mit solchen Motiven, so dass, wenn Frau Merkel etwas schneller ist als früher Sarkozy, ist das schon ein, jetzt muss er wieder dagegenhalten und so weiter sagen, ich hab mich durchgesetzt, nein, die haben sich durchgesetzt. Ich frage sie, woran erinnert uns das? Denken sie einfach an diese Diplomatie in Anführungszeichen. Wir sind jetzt schon in einem Diplomat der Kalten Kriege. Wir sind in einem diplomatischen Verhältnis zu unserer eigenen Öffentlichkeit. Politisch. Das hab ich jedenfalls so noch nicht erlebt. Und man wirft dann, man übertreibt mit dem Metapher, nein, die sind nur genommen. Ich hab das Wort Monster nicht erfunden. Ist nun der Herr Köhler ein verrückter? Nein. Er ist ein Sparkassenchef gewesen, er war einer der mächtigsten Ökonomen der Welt und Bundespräsident und ist dann zurückgetreten. Und er sagt Monster. Also das sind ja nicht wir, die das sagen, die das dann auf diese Begriffe bringen.
Interessant daran ist natürlich dann noch, dass diese Indirektheit der Kommunikation, also dieses Sending a Message, die kommt ja eigentlich auch aus dem Kalten Krieg.
Total.
Also insbesondere halt bei diesen ganzen Schläfer-Träterkriegen, angefangen von Korea und Vietnam, bis hin dann zu den afrikanischen und lateinamerikanischen Auseinandersetzungen zwischen den Großmächten, die Alproxy-Kriege waren und die die immer als so ein, ja uns geht es ja eigentlich gar nicht um das, was da eigentlich passiert in dem Land. Also gut, okay, Rollback des Kommunismus hin und her, sondern es geht darum, dass man nicht schwach aussieht, also dass man halt stark aufgestellt aussieht. Und aber klar ist, es gibt eine Obergrenze in dem Spiel.
Na das hat auch erst Afghanistan etabliert, oder? Das ist eine Obergrenze.
Nein, nein, nein, nein.
Da haben die doch nachgebuttert, bis sie nicht mehr konnten.
Afghanistan war der Punkt, wo ihnen die Obergrenze egal war. Also Afghanistan war der Punkt, wo allen klar war, was sie da tun und es ihnen dann irgendwann egal war, dass sie das Ding aus und was da reingebuttert haben.
Ich meine jetzt aus Sicht der Russen. Die Russen haben einfach...
Aus Sicht der Russen war tatsächlich Afghanistan, aber gut, aus Sicht der Russen war Afghanistan ja Hinterhof. Also es war halt irgendwie quasi... Afghanistan war natürlich sowohl strategisch als auch alles mögliche andere eine der größten Fehler, die die Sowjetunion je gemacht hat. Aber diese Logik dieser Proxy-Kommunikation, die fängt ja... also wenn wir jetzt mal so zurück gucken an den Finanzmärkten, dann ist die ja mit diesem Greenspan-Watching.
Daran hab ich auch gerade gedacht. Da gab es nämlich diesen Indikator zum Beispiel, ob er den Koffer in der linken oder der rechten Hand hält und daraus haben dann irgendwelche... was im Mittelhalter hatte man Leute, die die Knochen von Hühnchen hochwerfen und dann wie sie fallen und daraus irgendwelche Rückflüsse zogen. Und sowas gibt es auch in Finanzmärkten. Na klar, da werden gesagt, ja heute hat er einen sehr forschten Schritt drauf, das heißt es geht nach oben mit den Märkten.
Die Dicke seines Aktenkoffers.
Also groteske Indikatoren und genau wie heute. Im Grunde weiß keiner wirklich, was da passiert und deswegen macht man so.
Es sagt natürlich sofort der nüchterne Zuhörer oder Mensch, sowas hat es immer gegeben und ich glaube, dass das eben das ist, womit wir uns fälschlicherweise beruhigen. Es hat es Abiträer immer gegeben. Also aber in einer modernen Demokratie, auch mit ihren Kommunikationsmöglichkeiten, wirkt es, um das Wort von Ackermann zu verwenden, mittlerweile systemisch. Es war ja sogar so und das frage ich mich oft, wenn ich jetzt im Lese in Zeitungen und so, jetzt gibt es wieder die Expertise und die Expertise. Es war ja sogar so, das hat Bob Aumann erzählt, einer der wichtigsten Spiel theoretiker, Nobelpreisträger, vielleicht einer der wichtigsten überhaupt. Der hat gesagt, wir haben zum Teil sogar, um Leute in die Irre zu führen, wissenschaftliche Veröffentlichungen gemacht. Wir haben also Bluffs, unsere Expertisen, waren zum Teil Bluff, damit die Russen denken, dass wir denken, dass sie denken und so weiter. Also in dieses Spiel des Hineinversetzens, in die Erwartung eines anderen, der zu fehlt, der wiederum eine Erwartung über einen selber hat. Also dieses, das erinnert mich in seiner auch Verrücktheit, die es hat, an die Spiele, die wir heute, wenn wir die Zeitung aufschlagen oder auf eine Website gehen, sofort haben, wenn wir uns ins Innere des Gehirns von Angela Merkel und der italienischen Regierung oder wem auch immer, oder eines Bankers oder wem auch immer hineinversetzen. Also es scheint mir doch etliche an der Zeit zu sein, das nicht nur für etwas zu halten, oh jetzt haben wir mal so eine Krise und jetzt sind wir alle mal so ein bisschen durcheinander, sondern zu sehen, dass da eine Systematik dahinter ist. Und wenn Greenspan, was ich ja nicht oft genug zitiert, ist, dass man sich nicht so informieren kann, wenn man mich attackiert von Seiten der Ökonomen und das übertreibt. Wie habt ihr über Greenspan geredet? Das ist Frage 1 und Frage 2. Und der gleiche, über den ihr so geredet habt, hat vor dem amerikanischen Kongress, ich hab das schon mal gesagt, diese für mich zwei Sätze gesagt, die für mich relevant sind. Das erste in diesem unglaublichen Gespräch mit dem Senator Waxman, den Demokraten. Ich habe einen Fehler entdeckt. Darauf fragt ihr ihn was? Sie haben einen Fehler in der Wirklichkeit entdeckt? Nein, ich habe einen Fehler in der Theorie entdeckt. Sie haben Computer-Nobelpreisträgern vertraut und es stimmte nicht. Und der zweite Satz war der, das gesamte wissenschaftliche Denkgebäude ist zusammengebrochen. Und wenn man weiß, wo Greenspan herkommt, muss man so etwas, glaube ich, schon... Wir sind ja noch in der Phase der Beschreibung. Wird das ein späterer Historiker, kann daran ja nicht vorbeigehen. Wir können jetzt alle noch tausendmal zu tun, dass jeder weiß, was er tut. Ich frage mich, ob die Systeme wie bei dem Billy Wilder Film Dr. Seltsam nicht schon so sind, dass selbst die Beteiligten schon gar nicht mehr wissen, was sie glauben sollen und was nicht.
Den Eindruck habe ich in der Wirtschaft schon länger, ehrlich gesagt. Da gibt es halt so verschiedene Fraktionen mit ihren jeweiligen Dogmen. Und dass der Greenspan sich vor den Senat stellt und sagt, ja, wir haben halt den Nobelpreisregier vertraut, da komme ich doch wieder zurück auf den Anfang.
Und die Computer.
Na ja, klar, gut. Aber die Computer, das ist ja das schöne Computer, tun ja genau das, was man ihnen sagt, was sie tun sollen. So auch bei diesem Flashcrash, den sie da vorhin erwähnt haben. Das ist ja alles komplett vorhersagbar. Also Computern die Schuld in die Schuhe zu schieben, finde ich immer völlig absurd. Weil die haben wir dahingestellt und ihnen gesagt, was sie tun sollen. Aber wenn der Greenspan sich jetzt vor den Senat stellt und sagt, ja, wir haben halt den Nobelpreisregier vertraut, die hat er sich doch ausgesucht, welchen Nobelpreisregier er vertrauen soll. Es gab natürlich auch die Gegenthese. Aber selbstverständlich gab es die damals auch öffentlich. Also das war nicht irgendwie, da hätte man nicht mal nach suchen müssen, sondern die stand in der Zeitung, das stimmt alles nicht. Aber er hat sich halt ausgesucht, wer man vertrauen will und hat dann versucht, das zu deflektieren und zu sagen, das war aber nicht meine Schuld, sondern ich hab nur Befehle befolgt.
Unterstützt von der Politik, die da genau das gleiche Spielbild spielen.
Die wollen auch alle ihren Hals aus der Schlinge ziehen.
Ich meine, worum es ja am Ende geht, ist ja die Frage des Versuchs mit solchen Modellen und Vorhersagen und auch ökonomischen Theorien, sowas wie Gewissheit zu erlangen. Also Planbarkeit zu erlangen. Und natürlich irgendwie daraus Profi zu schlagen. Interessanterweise hat uns aber dieser Versuch, dahin zu kommen, eigentlich ins genaue Gegenteil gebracht. Was sie nämlich gesagt haben, dieses Ich weiß, dass du weißt, das ich weiß, dass du weißt, ist ja genau James Jesus Engelton, der CIA-Chef, der verrückt geworden ist. Und der sprach halt von der Wilderness of Mirrors, also der Wildnis aus Spiegeln. Also ein Spiegelkabinett quasi, wo man, wenn man drin ist, nicht mehr weiß, ob man jetzt irgendwie seine eigenen Gedanken im Spiegel sieht oder die des Gegners oder die Reflexion und Verzerrung, und es eigentlich keine Wahrheit mehr gibt. Und der Engelton ist halt darüber verrückt geworden, dass er davon überzeugt war, dass es einen extrem hochrangigen sowjetischen Spion im CIA gibt. Und hat da halt irgendwie endlose Hetzejagden veranstaltet. Und irgendwann zwischendurch kam er auf die Idee, dass er selber möglicherweise der sowjetische Spion sein könnte. Und diese Wilderness of Mirrors ist aber genau das, was wir ja jetzt an den Börsen sehen. Also die, warum gab es denn diesen Flash-Crash? So ein schönes Beispiel, da kommen wir bestimmt noch mal drauf zurück. Basierend auf diesem falschen, also gehackten Tweet bei Epi. Der Grund ist, dass die Folgerung, warum irgendwas passiert, also warum bewegt sich dieser und jener Indikator hoch oder runter, ist nicht mehr von Logik getrieben, sondern nur noch von dem Versuch, mit maschinellen Mitteln Korrelation zu finden.
Genau, aber das war doch nie... Doch, doch, also das halte ich für ein Gerücht, das merkte irgendwann mal...
Nein, doch, also die orthodoxe Ökonomie, bevor es maschinellen Handel gab, also bevor es die Möglichkeit gab, dass du beliebige Indikatoren mit beliebigen Dingen, in historischen Daten korrelieren kannst, das was die Quans gerade tun, war die traditionelle Ökonomie hat immer versucht, einen Grund zu finden, eine Logik zu finden, um zu sagen, wenn sich diese fundamental Indikatoren nach oben oder unten bewegen, denn wenn mehr Stahl verkauft und mehr Kohle verkauft wird, dann so, ne? Also quasi sozusagen logische Zusammenhänge zu finden, aus denen man sozusagen ableiten kann, wie sich die Zukunft bewegen wird. Und dann gab es immer noch allerhand Erklärungen, warum das jetzt gerade mal nicht geklappt hat, weil irgendwie noch dieser Indikator dazwischen kam. Das hörte dann so ein bisschen auf, als die Chart-Techniker ankamen.
Oh, das ist alles ein Bullshit, ich hab kein Wort von diesen.
Also die Chart-Techniker, muss irgendwie für die, die sich nicht mehr so erinnern. Das ist wie Bob Ross, oder? Moment, lass mich doch mal kurz erklären, was die Chart-Techniker gemacht haben. Einfach nur, damit man in der Unterhaltung hörbar. Und zwar die Chart-Techniker sind Leute, die auf die Kurven von Indices, also von Aktienkursen oder Währungskursen, noch mal gucken. Und dann musste in den Kurven sehen und sagen, okay, also hier gibt es eine wichtige Unterstützungslinie bei sowieso. Ihr erinnert euch noch Dunkel?
Völlig aus den Haaren gedrogen.
Da gibt es dann so Kurven, die sich da zurechtgerechnet haben, die lustigerweise am Anfang irgendwann sogar mal stimmten.
Ja, wenn es alle glauben sollen.
Nein, nein, Moment. Die funktionierten tatsächlich so lange, diese Kurven, dass es tatsächlich Abhängigkeiten gab, wo die es für sich behalten haben. Also, wo niemand wusste, dass ich...
Sehr interessant, wie bei der Black-Scholes-Formel.
Ja, genau diese... Und jeder einzeln diese Erkenntnisse oder Pseudoerkennnisse aus diesen Chart-Analyse oder auch diesen Korrelationen von Indikatoren, die funktionierte genau so lange, bis alle davon wussten.
Na, was meinte ich auch für eine steile These, ehrlich gesagt.
Na ja, zumindest so ungefähr, über den Daumen.
Das ist übrigens für die berühmte Black-Scholes-Formel. Da ist es nachgewiesen. Das war ein System, das funktionierte halt nur, als Vorhersage von künftigen Preisentwicklungen. Funktionierte ja am Anfang wunderbar, sodass die ja Nobelpreis, mit dem Nobelpreis in der Hand, auch ihren eigenen Fonds gründeten. Aber es funktionierte eben in dem Moment, nicht mehr wie immer, in solchen Systemen, wo dann die Gruppe derjenigen, die das System so benutzten, eben zu groß war und die kritische Masse erreicht wurde. Weil dadurch dieser Faktor weg war, dieser Happy-Few, die die Analytik hatten.
Na nicht nur das, das ist ein üblicher Fehler in der Softwareentwicklung und in der Informatik generell, dass eben Algorithmen mit der Prämisse gemacht werden, dass man davon ausgeht, dass alle Teilnehmer gutwillig sind. Weil alle wollen die Software...
Oder sich so verhalten wie vorher.
Genau, oder sich weiterhin so verhalten wie bisher. Und das kann man eben nicht sagen. In dem Moment, wo man sowas veröffentlicht und wo damit Geld gemacht werden kann, wird es Leute geben, die sich da als Antagonisten etablieren und gegen das System spielen, um es kaputt zu machen, weil man damit Profit machen kann.
Oder es halt benutzen und dadurch halt für überproportionale Verstärkung sorgen.
Ich will dir noch kurz eine Anekdote erzählen, weil ich hier gerade ein Buch lese, das heißt Thinking Fast and Slow von Daniel Kahnemann. Und der hat sich genau dieses Ding, das wir uns bei den Börsenindikatoren Sachen aussuchen, hat er sich mal angeguckt und hat an dem Tag als, was war das jetzt, die Billanenverhaftung, oder eine von diesen Geschichten, irgendein Event oder dieser Damm gefunden, oder irgendwie so eine Nummer war das, da gingen die Märkte erst nach unten. Und weil die Botschaft des Tages, die Nachricht des Tages war aber binladen gefasst, deswegen waren alle Erklärungen im Börsenfernsehen über irgendeine Bewegung am Aktienmarkt waren alle, naja, das ist wegen binladen und der Markt glaubt jetzt. Und dann ging es wieder nach oben und dann war es auch binladen. Also das heißt, diese Idee, dass wir da jetzt eine Erklärung für haben, das ist alles reine Psychologie, das gibt keine wirklichen Erklärungen. Wir haben auch nie wirklich einen Beweis dafür, dass wir irgendwas erklären können, sondern wir haben irgendwann eine Geschichte. Und wenn die Geschichte so halbwegs in sich stimmig klingt, dann sind wir auch gewillt, die zu glauben. Und so funktioniert das an den Börsen, im Fernsehen, wenn die erklären, warum gerade der Kurs von irgendwas so runtergegangen ist, das ist alles Kaffeesatzleserei.
Ich würde gerne, was Frank Rieger sagte, ein Stück nur weiter drehen, weil das ist der Unterschied zwischen Korrelation auf der Einsachen und Ursachen. Wenn man sich anschaut, wie jetzt, das ist ein Auszug in Foreign Affairs über Big Data. Die sind da sehr positiv und affirmativ. Wir müssen darüber nachdenken, dass wir in eine Gesellschaft hineingehen, allmählich, in der tatsächlich die Frage nach den Ursachen, also auch der Gedanke, dass es eine Ursache gibt, die man mit der Analyse und mit dem Kopf erreichen kann, sei es menschliches Verhalten, immer mehr in den Hintergrund gedruckt wird und stattdessen die Korrelation wichtig wird. Und die Korrelation, die einfach nur sagt, da besteht bei den und den Auffälligkeiten das Risiko, dass dieser Aktie oder dieser Mensch oder was auch immer, dass wir also uns entfernen von der ja fast aufklärerischen Attitüde. Es gibt für etwas eine Ursache, die kann man aufklären. Über die muss man auch nachdenken, wie sie entstanden ist. Das ist ein ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Genau diese Verwechslung von Korrelation und Kausation. Kausalität. Kausalität, Entschuldigung. Die Frage, gibt es denn tatsächlich eine Ursache und eine Wirkung? Oder sieht es nur so aus? Die wird ja immer mehr dahingehend beantwortet, dass man sagt, eigentlich ist es auch egal.
Wir können die nicht beantworten. Nein, Moment. Denn wir wissen es deswegen nicht, weil wir auch die Korrelation nicht selber gefunden haben, sondern die hat diese Software gefunden.
Genau.
Das heißt, wir können überhaupt nicht mehr nachvollziehen, was da eigentlich genau korreliert. Das kann auch ein Artifakt von unserer Datenerhebung sein. Aber das wissen wir alles nicht, weil das nämlich unsere Software gesehen hat. Und wir können es zwar bestätigen, wenn wir uns diese Kurven ansehen, dann sehen wir, ja, da gibt es eine Korrelation. Aber was jetzt was auslöst, die Frage, auf die haben wir auch gar nicht optimiert, weil uns das für unsere Modelle egal ist.
Und jetzt sage ich voraus, die nächste große Wende wird sein, dass wir jetzt überall lesen werden, wird aus Amerika stark kommen. Wir müssen lernen, aber das ist ganz anders gemeint, mit Unsicherheiten zu leben. Klingt ja erst mal gut. Damit ist aber gemeint, so meine Prognose, dass wir sagen werden, die und die Korrelation sagen mir bei dem und Menschen das und das Risiko voraus. Ich kann dessen nicht ganz sicher sein. Aber, und da kommen immer sehr positive Beispiele, wenn es reicht, dass ich den von der Trunksucht abhalte, jetzt sind ja reale Beispiele, die ich sozio-demografisch ausfahre, oder wenn ich ihn von einem Verbrechen abhalte, Polizei von Los Angeles und so weiter. Das wird eine ganz große Sache sein. Wir werden bekommen, das klingt erst super, wir müssen uns mal wieder bekennen zur Unsicherheit, gemeint ist aber, dass man, glaube ich, in diese neue Phase geht über Korrelationen, die man das Risiko einzugehen. Es könnte sein, wenn die Krankenkasse neben das und das voraussieht, dass es bei dem gar nicht dazu kommt. Aber das können wir eingehen, weil die Chance, dass wir jemandem helfen, in Anführungszeichen viel größer ist.
Ich finde das operative Wort an der Stelle einpreisen. Das ist nämlich das Wort, was ich großartig finde und mich jedes Mal gefreut, wenn es im Fernsehen kommt. Das hat der Markt schon eingepreist.
Und das wird auf die soziale Welt übertragen.
Das ist auch jetzt schon so und auch diese Idee, wir wissen nicht, ob das passieren wird oder nicht, das haben wir auch schon länger in der Medizin bei Krebsvorsorge. Da hat man ja auch so Indikatoren und sagt, naja, das ist wahrscheinlich, dass der Brosser da Krebs kriegt oder so. Wahrscheinlich, ja, als was weiß ich. Diese Genforschung in Amerika, dass man seine Gendaten irgendwo hinschickt und dann irgendwie 100 Dollar zahlt. Oder, ich weiß jetzt nicht, was es tatsächlich kostet, aber relativ günstig. Und dann machen die einem da nur Analyse und sagen einem, du hast eine erblich bedingte, höhere Wahrscheinlichkeit für bla bla. Und dann macht man eine Krebsuntersuchung. Das gibt's jetzt schon. Aber das Ergebnis ist spannenderweise nicht eindeutig positiv. Im Gegenteil, sondern es gibt jetzt viel mehr Hysterie und die Leute lassen sich irgendwelche Sachen raus operieren. Und unterm Strich geht der Krebs aber nicht zurück.
Das hat ja der Gigerrenzer in Sachen Prostata nachgewiesen. Aber ich frag mich, was heißt das für Soziale? Also bei den Sachen, die zum Beispiel soziale Prognosen abgeben. Natürlich auch kriminelle Prognosen. Das wird sowieso kommen. Ein Hinweis noch, weil wir von der Spieltheorie hier aus gingen. Auch hier gibt es viele Irrtümer. Also auch bei Leuten, die da über mich sich äußerten. Man kann, und ich warte auf das Gegenbeispiel, dann bin ich gerne bereit, mich sofort zu korrigieren. Aber ich habe mit vielen geredet, die diese Systeme konstruieren, bauen, auch an Börsen bauen, auch an der Wall Street bauen. Auf der Ebene der Transaktionen, wie sie heute und vielleicht die Zukunft abbildet, der Einmalaktion, der anonymen Einmalinteraktion, ist es unmöglich, sie anders zu modellieren als durch den sogenannten egoistischen Agenten. Es gibt, die kooperativen Modelle spielen dort keine Rolle. Und ich erwähne das nur deshalb, weil ja im Hintergrund unseres Gesprächs und für mich jedenfalls immer wieder die Frage steht, wie kann es sein, und ich glaube, dass wir mittlerweile in dem Zustand sind, dass wir hier sehenden Auges in einem Europa leben, wo wir ständig, das ist doch wie das Bild dieser Krise, ständig von Kooperation, das ist ja die Idee des Ganzen, Europa und wir es gleichzeitig in die Luft fliegen lassen. Also dieser Widerspruch, dass im Grunde ein egoistischer Agent im Inneren arbeitet, wir alle noch immer glauben, das Endziel ist aber eine große, wunderbare europäische Kooperation. Wir leben jetzt, dass genau das Gegenteil eintritt. Und da glaube ich, gibt es eine Linie, die von dem ganz kleinen, programmierten, sehr dummen, Zero-Intelligence-haften Agenten beginnt. Und die geht bis zur europäischen Politik.
Aber was mir gerade auffällt, ist, dass der Kern der momentan deutschen europäischen Finanzpolitik, nämlich diese Asteroid-Nummer, ist ja genau das, nämlich dass wir nicht mehr eine Wahrheit als Kern oder eine Erkenntnis, eine logische Einsicht, eine Folgerung als Kern der Politik haben, sondern nur noch eine statistische Korrelation. Die sich als falsch herausstellte, nämlich dass Staaten, die eine Verschuldung haben, die über einem bestimmten Punkt liegt, dass diese sowieso in eine Krise stürzen, dass es deswegen umso wichtiger ist, die Verschuldung in diesen Staaten zurückzudrehen. Koste es, was es wolle? Das war ja keine logische Folge. Es war jetzt nicht so, dass es eine ökonomische Theorie gab, die sagte, warum ist denn das so? Es war tatsächlich eine statistische Annahme, die halt einfach nur sagte, wir haben hier eine Gruppe von 35 Staaten und in diesen 35 Staaten, die immer über eine Staatsverschuldungsquote von 2,9% kamen, ist irgendwie ein Jahre später die Wirtschaft zusammengebrochen.
Und wir müssen gleich hinzufügen, dass bei zweien Spanien und Irland das ja gar nicht der Fall war.
Das kommt noch und so. Und es war tatsächlich obendrein auch noch falsch. Also dieses gesamte Korrelationsgebäude, was halt eben eine Kausation annahm, also eine Kausalität annahm, also tatsächlich diese Annahme versuchte zu sagen, okay, ist es bei 30 Staaten und 35 Staaten so gewesen, also wird es immer so sein? Und der Vernachlässigung aller möglicher Faktoren, die ist ja wieder so ganz klassisch dafür, dass, wie wenn man versucht mit wissenschaftlichen Methoden, also nehmen wir mal so Physik oder so, da ist es ja ein übliches Vorgehen, dass man sagt, okay, man reduziert den betrachteten Raum von dem, was man sich anguckt, also in seinem Experiment oder seine Anzahl der Faktoren, um möglichst eine knackige Theorie bilden zu können. Also man versucht halt einfach nicht.
Na und auch, um das messen und nachprüfen zu können.
Genau, also um halt die Nachprüfbarkeit irgendwie zu erzeugen. Und genau das haben die ja da getan. Die haben sich auf einen einzigen Faktor konzentriert und haben den Rest irgendwie mehr oder weniger wegdiskutiert und haben gesagt so, hier diese Staatsverschuldung, die ist es so. Und dann haben die ganzen anderen Sachen wie Arbeitslosigkeit und so weiter sofort völlig außer Acht gelassen. Und der Unterschied dazu ist aber, dass ja die Ökonomen haben es ja nicht mit Naturgesetzen zu tun, auch wenn sie gerne so tun. Sie haben halt tatsächlich mit Bewegungen zu tun, die aus menschlichem Zusammenleben entstehen. Und da kommen wir dann wieder zurück zu ihrem Buch, nämlich die These, die sie ja aufstellen, ist, dass der Versuch, diese Berechenbarkeit herzustellen, ja einer der Gründe ist, warum unser Denken und unser Verhalten ummodelliert werden sollte, hin zu einem, dass wir uns verhalten wie egoistische Agenden.
Daran kann überhaupt kein Zweifeln bestehen, weil dazu brauche ich noch nicht mal die Beweise, die wir haben aus den sozialpsychologischen Studien. Es ist doch ganz klar, wenn wir kommunizieren und einer von uns beiden die absolute Überzeugung hat, dass alles, was sie tun, während wir hier reden, ihrem eigenen egoistischen, nur dem Nutzt, selbst wenn sie bei mir was Gutes tun, ist doch klar, dass sie sich dadurch auch verändern. Und wir wissen das, das ist ein Modell, das annimmt. Jeder handelt selbst im Altruismus nur aus Eigennutz tatsächlich das, was es beschreibt, schafft. Wir reden nicht von Naturgesetzen. Wir reden nicht von den Planetenbewegungen, denen es völlig egal, ob es ein Gesetz gibt oder nicht. Die bewegen sich so. Bei Menschen ist das etwas anderes. Diese angeblichen Gesetzmäßigkeiten haben die unangenehme Eigenschaft, und ich finde, das kann man in der Entwicklung der amerikanischen Gesellschaft sehen, haben die unangenehme Eigenschaft, ein Verhalten, das sie beschreiben, normativ herzustellen, wie überhaupt im Zusammenhang mit der Spieltheorie. Das ist ja kein Gesetz, das ist ja eine Heuristik, das ist ja normativ. Das ist ja eine Festlegung, wenn sie so wollen eine Vorschrift. In Zeiten, wo die mit dem Papier dort saßen und mit dem Stift, und das gibt es ja alles, alles dokumentiert, ihre schönen Pattern und die Kästen und so weiter, mag das ja alles noch hingehen. In dem Zeitalter von Echtzeitkommunikation und Echtzeitsystem, wo dies als mathematische Modell implementiert ist, da wird es natürlich dann völlig anders. Und da kann ich nur auf die Flashcrest seit 2010 hinweisen. Der Scott Patterson hat das sehr genau beschrieben, was da in diesen Dark Pools sich so abspielt. Und der kann das gar nicht anders. Der muss sich sogar jetzt in so einen Darwinismus flüchten, dass er so von Piranhas redet und von Raubtieren und so weiter. Aber da ist es, da haben sie wirklich, wenn wir je dieses Systems gone wild Phänomen hatten, dann haben wir es seit 2010 schon drei oder vier mal gehabt, wahrscheinlich schon viel, viel öfter. Und jetzt kommt das, worüber wir hier die ganze Zeit reden. Ich frage dann meine Kollegen manchmal und dann gibt es natürlich welche, die sagen, nein, du hast nicht recht und das stimmt nicht. Und dennoch können sie mir keine Antwort auf die einfache Frage geben, hat jemand diese Flash-Tracks erklären können? Weiß jemand, was da eigentlich vor sich geht? Einer der Wirtschaftsinformatiker in Deutschland, der das sehr elementar mitgewirkt hat, 2001 dabei, sagt mir wörtlich, wir wissen nicht mehr, was die tun. Und auch das ist jetzt nicht aus dem Science-Fiction-Film. Wir wissen nur, was ihr Interesse ist. Und das ist, den anderen in die Irre führen, vom anderen das Schlechteste annehmen und mit eigenen Profiten möglichst in Echtzeit zu maximieren.
Da müsste ich vielleicht noch ein paar Sachen noch kurz nachtragen. Also vorhin diese Aussage zu den Osteritiesahnen, da möchte ich vielleicht noch hinzufügen, dass dieses ganze Paper schon ein apologieten Projekt war. Denn vorher, also diese Idee, dass man Ländern Sparzwang auferlegt, damit es ihnen besser geht, das versucht ja der Weltwährungsfonds seit 50 Jahren. Und das hat noch nie funktioniert. Es gibt nicht ein Beispiel, wo das jemals funktioniert hätte. Das geht den Ländern immer schlechter danach. Wenn man sagt, ja, sie müssen hier sparen, da sparen.
Die WMF-Riots, genau.
Ihr traf natürlich. Das ist doch, das ist verbrieft. Das ist wie das Abend in der Kirche, wenn man nicht...
Kurz zur Erklärung, die WMF-Riots sind, man kann mittlerweile die Uhr danach stellen, wenn der Weltwährungsfonds sagt, ihr müsst jetzt mal irgendwie Osterity machen, gibt es irgendwie 18 Monate später Riots. Also so kann man die Uhr danach stellen.
Ausschreitungen auf der Straße, weil den Leuten, wenn der Staat sparen muss, dann spart er bei den Subventionen und das sind so Sachen wie Lebensmittel, Benzin, dann können die Leute nicht mehr heizen und natürlich gibt es dann irgendwann Ausschreitungen. Also das ist seit ewigen Zeiten bekannt, aber widerspricht eben der landläufigen Theorie, dem Dogma, was diese Fraktion der Wirtschaftswissenschaftler eben vertreten hat. Und um zu beweisen, dass hinter ihrem Dogma mehr steht als eine Fantasie, haben die eben diese kaputte Excel-Tabelle gemacht, die dann das Gegenteil beweisen sollte. Und wie wir jetzt gesehen haben, waren nicht nur die Daten falsch, die da reingetan wurden, sondern auch die Formeln in der Tabelle waren falsch. Und das ist eine einzige Megakatastrophe. Aber es kann wirklich niemand sagen, dass das vorher nicht klar war. Also wir haben es geglaubt, weil wir es glauben wollten. Also jetzt wir nicht im Sinne von ich oder wir hier, sondern die Medien und die Gesellschaft hat es geglaubt, weil wir gerne glauben wollten, dass die Politik so im Groben schon weiß, was sie tut. Dass es irgendjemanden gibt auf der Welt, der einen Plan hat, was hier gerade passiert. Denn die Alternative wäre ja gewesen zu sagen, keiner hat eine Ahnung, was hier passiert. Das mag zwar im Groben stimmen, aber das will man ja nicht so als Weltbild haben. Da kann man ja nachts nicht mehr schlafen.
Ich glaube ja, dass die Alternative, wir müssen darüber noch reden, die Alternative eine ganz andere ist. Auch der Ausweg ein ganz anderer ist. Aber ich möchte sagen, zu dem was Fefe sagte, ich selber zum Beispiel, ich bekenne mich natürlich dazu, ich bin kein Ökonom. Ich finde aber in einer Welt, wo wir selbst einem Aspirin nicht trauen. Also sagen, wer weiß, was es für Nebenwirkungen hat. Dann kann es keine Wissenschaft mehr geben, die imperialistisch alles deutet. Und wir sind noch nicht mal, sobald wir sie in Frage stellen, siehe diese Tabellen, jetzt ist es ja evident, gelten wir, der versteht nichts von der Sache. Oder das ist Wissenschaft oder was auch immer. Das ist eine Form von Hegemonie, die jetzt mittlerweile sogar das intimste Leben, das ja auch schon ökonomisiert wird, erreicht. Wie muss ich, und die Leute sehen die Widersprüche ja täglich. Jetzt sind die Zinsen so niedrig, dass ihre Altersvorsorgung, ihre ganzen privaten Sparpläne, all das, was man ihnen empfohlen hat, alles nicht mehr funktioniert. Das heißt, da ist ja eine Empirie da, dass da irgendetwas nicht funktioniert.
Aber so muss man eine kurze Frage dazu. Weil also die Frage, was mit der Wissenschaft passiert und der Glaubwürdigkeit von Wissenschaft. Ich glaube, dass einer der größten Hypotheken, die uns diese Ökonomie eingebrockt hat, also die Ökonomie als Wissenschaft, ist ja, dass sie sich als Wissenschaft bezeichnet.
Das ist ja der Punkt, das hat der Mirovski. Er hat das ja dargestellt, wie die im 19. Jahrhundert angefangen haben, da fing das an, die Modelle der Physik zu übernehmen. Zum Teil, wie er ja gezeigt hat in More Heat Than Light, sogar noch mit falsch verstanden. Und dieser, da gibt es natürlich immer Gegenstimmen. Das ist ja klar, die werden aber immer schwächer. Und dann kommt plötzlich dieses Idee, dieser Traum geradezu und durch den Computer befördert. Man könnte eine positive Wissenschaft werden. Und jetzt muss ich auch sagen, also vielleicht ist das ungerecht. Ich kenne keine, auch wenn sie so an Talkshows denken und was auch immer wir alles haben, Zeitungen. Ich kenne eigentlich nichts. Zwar kritisieren wir alle irgendwie ökonomische Prozesse, aber das wirkliche in Fragestellung dieses Anspruchs, das ist die einzige Wissenschaft, wo das nicht. Jede Wissenschaft wird in Frage gestellt. Aber diese wird zumindest noch nicht mal als Sozialwissenschaft akzeptiert. Ich will etwas sagen zu der aktuellen Debatte, die wir da hatten zur Spieltheorie. Ich habe dann Ariel Rubinstein gebeten, nachdem mir das etwas zu bunt war, mit diesen Lexikon-Antworten auf das angeblich kooperative Spieltheorie. Auch Rubinstein ist ein großer Spieltheoretiker. Er ist der Meinung, dass man es eigentlich nicht lehren sollte, weil es Menschen verändert. Davon ist er überzeugt, auch wenn es empirische Gegenbeweise gibt. Er beschreibt in der Szene, die ich erwähne, wie er an einem Basar mal theoretisch handeln wollte. Und der Basarhändler sagt in Jerusalem war das. Hör zu, wir handeln hier seit 2000 Jahren, jetzt kommst du mit sowas. Das ist ja grotesk oder so ähnlich. Und jedenfalls ging der Scham es rot weg. Und hier ist eines wichtig, er sagt, und vielleicht führt das jetzt auch zu weit, aber ich wollte es nur mal erwähnt haben, er sagt, das ganze Problem, da geht es jetzt sehr ins Technische mit dem Nash-Equilibrium. Und das ist nämlich genau das Problem und dem egoistischen Agenten. Es ist schon nicht gut, dass wir es zur Analytik benutzen, aber es wird zur Prognostik verwendet. Es wird also zur Voraussage verwendet. Es ist implementiert zum Beispiel auch in Überwachungssystemen und Ähnlichem, das wissen wir. Und da wird es halt besonders heikel. Und interessanterweise attackiert er da, ich will das jetzt nicht polemisch, mit diesen Sätzen jemanden, der das glaubt. Und derjenige ist der Chief Economist Advisor von Google. Selber ein Spieltheoretiker.
Na gut, zu Google kommen wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen später.
Ich muss hier noch kurz ein Zitat nochmal bringen, das haben wir schon bei Alternativlos23 gehabt, aber das passt gerade sehr gut. Da ging es nämlich um Max Planck. Und der hat gesagt, eine neue wissenschaftliche Wahrheit pflegt sich nicht in der Weise durchzusetzen, dass ihre Gegner überzeugt werden und sich als belehrt erklären, sondern vielmehr dadurch, dass ihre Gegner allmählich aussterben und dass die heranwachsende Generation von vorne heran mit der Wahrheit vertraut gemacht ist. Das heißt auch in der Physik ist es nicht so, dass die Fakten überzeugen. Das ist eigentlich, also das ist natürlich, so möchte man es gerne sehen, aber es stimmt auch nur partiell in der Physik. Und in der Ökonomie stimmt es schon mal gar nicht, ist mein Eindruck. Sondern da gibt es halt soziale Klicken und setzt sich halt irgendeine durch. Aber nicht aufgrund von inhaltlicher Überlegenheit oder weil sie mehr Sachen erklären kann, sondern einfach weil es die größere Gruppe ist. Und im Nachhinein hat noch nie irgendeiner Recht gehabt von denen.
Aber jetzt habe ich eine Frage an sie beide, weil sie ja in diesem System leben. Sie sind, die wohnen da ja auch drin. Also mir kommt es ja so vor, dass die, ich glaube die Beschreibung, die wir jetzt haben, gibt es auch hier, dass das immer mehr, ohne dass wir es richtig merken, auch von der Merkel und von allen, wie ein fast von außen auch gar nicht mehr zu beeinflossendes, geschlossenes System abläuft im Augenblick. Also auch in der Zeitung, zwar hier ein bisschen Zinsen senken, da mal eine Rede halten und so weiter, aber im Grunde ist es wie ein Prozess der Autonom. Meine Hoffnung, und das meinte ich vorhin mit Politik oder meine Erforderung wäre ja, ich glaube, dass Politik schon so angesteckt ist von diesem Denken, dass sie sich gar nicht mehr zutraut, sozusagen das dagegen zu tun, was das Einzige ist, was man gegen tun, nämlich politische Entscheidungen zu treffen, die nicht abgesichert sind, die nicht risikoabgesichert sind, die nicht umfragen ab und so weiter. Da würde mich eben ihre Erfahrung auch interessieren, ob es möglich ist, dass, wenn man in die solchen Systemen zu Hause ist, wie mittlerweile die ganze Gesellschaft bewegt sich da hinein, wie in einer Maschine, ob das allmählich tatsächlich zu einem Gefühl wird, wenn man z.B. Code analysiert wie Fefe, dass tatsächlich die ganze Welt ein geschlossenes System ist. Sie wissen, was ich meine.
Ich möchte eine Parallele noch kurz zeigen. Und zwar gibt es ja dieses schöne Buch, The Selfish Gene, was die These aufstellt, dass der Mensch gar nicht das Lebewesen ist, sondern das Gen ist das Lebewesen. Und der Mensch ist die Methode, wie das Gen sich verpflanzt. Das heißt, wir sollten uns nicht als die Agenten sehen, sondern als die Maschinen, die für die Agenten arbeiten. Fand ich damals bahnbrechend, die Idee. Aber im Grunde ist ja dasselbe, was wir jetzt über die Märkte lernen.
Ja, es ist die Ideologie.
Dass wir im Grunde, wenn wir ferngesteuert sind und wir arbeiten nicht für uns, im Gegenteil. Also je mehr wir sehen, fast niemand tut irgendwas, weil er es gerne tun möchte, sondern man tut es, wenn man dafür Geld kriegt. Also diese Idee, dass alle Leute aus Egoismus für sich nur für ihren eigenen Vorteil, stimmt ja hinten und vorne nicht. Aber das kann man schon beobachten.
Das ist aber sehr gut, wenn ich hier nur mal sage, der Dawkins sagt zum Beispiel, ich finde ja ihn in Hauptideologen bei dem ganzen Spiel, das Gene ist so lange im Körper, solange es sich eben reproduzieren kann. Und wenn es ihn dann, dann verlässt es ihn. Also er stirbt und verlässt ihn, geht in den anderen Körper, also durch Zeugung und so weiter. Übertragen wird das mal auf die heutige Bilder von Arbeitswelt. Wenn es keine Altersversorgung mehr in dem klassischen Sinne gibt, also diese Modelle haben man.
Also gut, ich meine, man muss sehr verstehen halt auch sagen, dass die Rezeption des Buches natürlich irgendwie sehr von seinem Titel bestimmt war.
Das sehe ich ganz anders.
Also Moment, die Rezeption. Der Punkt ist ja, dass tatsächlich die Rezeption ist ja das, was am Ende zählt. Also ich meine, die Intention ist...
Du kennst die Enron-Stelle, der Enron-Chef, der einmal im Jahr nach seinem Lieblingsbuch Selfish Gene eine Selektion durchführt.
Aber gut, das kann ich dir doch nicht sagen. Aber genau das ist ja der Punkt. Also da müssen wir noch mal ein kleines bisschen zurückgehen. Worauf ich hinaus will, ist nämlich tatsächlich die Macht der Ideen. Weil wir, wovon wir die ganze Zeit reden, ist, dass der Markt und auch die Art und Weise, wie Politik heutzutage gemacht wird, ja darauf beruht, dass Leute an Theorien glauben oder an Ideen und Ideale glauben.
An Dogmen. Ich bin ein bisschen negativer.
Wenn du da ein bisschen negativer hinkriegst. Und wobei aber es am besten ist, wenn so eine Idee wissenschaftlich unterfüttert ist oder zumindest so aussieht. Also sie hat einfach irgendeine Art von Fundament.
Das ist der Punkt.
Die halt irgendwie so gut aussieht. Also dass man sich halt sowohl auf der emotionalen, als auch auf der logischen Ebene damit wohlfühlt, weil es halt irgendwie zumindest keine offensichtlichen inherenten Widersprüche gibt.
Und der Typ, der es gemacht hat, der hat einen Nobelpreis. Einen Wirtschaftsnobelpreis aber immerhin.
So und wenn wir jetzt mal so zurückgehen zu dieser Egoismusgeschichte, dann ist ja so der Ursprung dieser ganzen Sache, ist er Henrent. Da müssen wir noch mal drüber reden. Das ist halt einfach der, wenn wir uns angucken, wer die ideologische Einflussnahme von Anfang an auf diese ganzen Leute hatte, die jetzt heute diese Banken fahren und die halt irgendwie die Trader, die Silicon Valley Leute, dann kommen wir immer wieder zu Henrent zurück.
Greenspan.
Ja Greenspan. Also alle durch die Bank. Also die ganzen Akteure da sagen alle, wenn man sie fragt nach ihrem Lieblingsbuch, dann sagen die Atlas Shrugged oder eins von den anderen zwei Büchern da. Also auch Dawkins, also auch dieses Selfish Gene ist ja quasi sozusagen die wissenschaftliche Argumentation für die Ayn Rand Ideologie in der Rezeption. Wie gesagt, in den Details kann man darüber streiten, aber die Auswirkungen und die Rezeption des Ganzen, also wie die Leute es wahrgenommen haben, nämlich als Rechtfertigung für einen bedingungslosen Egoismus. Und da ist mir neulich eine interessante Geschichte untergekommen, nämlich diese Untersuchung über die Korrelation zwischen psychopathischen Verhaltensweisen und soziopathischen Verhaltensweisen und Aufstieg bei Banken und Ähnlichem. Dass tatsächlich dann eine relativ hohe Koinzidenz da ist von Leuten, die man eigentlich lieber nicht in seiner Umgebung haben möchte, weil sie halt Soziopathen oder Psychopathen sind und Leuten, die halt in besonders stark Egoismus geprägten Karriereumfällen Erfolg haben. Also die halt einfach wo Ellenbogen gefragt ist und Durchsetzung um jeden Preis. Und die Korrelation von diesen Leuten mit Leuten, die in Banken Erfolg haben, ist ja nun gut untersucht. Was mich ja mal interessieren würde ist, was ist eigentlich mit Politikern? Vielleicht können Sie ja dazu sagen, die kennen Sie ja nicht.
Ich habe einige dieser Banker ja gesehen, welche die dann wirklich noch ein Jahr vorher über die Zeitung sagten, da ein Business, und dann plötzlich die Verstaatlichung forderten, solche Leute. Und auch in Amerika, man kennt ja dann, wenn man das recherchiert, dann kommt man ja auch mit gefallenen Stengeln in Verbindung und so weiter. Ich glaube, was wir sehen müssen, und da sind wir halt, sagen wir mal so, ein Rant kommt nach Europa, aber nicht als Idee, sondern in der Maschine. So wäre meine These. Ich glaube, das ist eben das, was ich mittlerweile überzeugt bin, wenn ich auch sehe, was sich in unseren Medien tut, was sich in unseren Verlagen tut, überall wo Geist reproduziert wird sozusagen. Ich glaube, dass Dawkins, das war nicht ein verabredetes Spiel, sondern das ist natürlich klar zu erkennen, warum das so passierte. Spieltheorie, viele andere Details, Kybernetik partiell, vor allen Dingen Ökonomie, haben im Kalten Krieg eine große Maschine gebaut. Eine Maschine, die zunächst, ich glaube, wir reden von einer Maschine, wir reden nicht darum, auch Natur gesetzt, das ist eigentlich das falsche Wort. Das ist die Funktionsweise einer Maschine, die wir sehen. Und das Problem bei dieser Maschine war immer der Homo sapiens, war immer wir. Wir waren zu wenig Homo economicus und das haben die ja auch gesagt. Nier Vulkan, den der Mirowski zitiert, der sagte zusammen mit Binnenmoor, sagte, wir hatten immer ein Problem, das war der Mensch. Aber jetzt, wo wir die digitalen Systeme haben, können wir endlich sehen, die funktionieren mit unseren Theorien fantastisch. Jetzt müssen wir nur noch versuchen, den Menschen da so Cyborg-mäßig anzudocken und zu verschmelzen, dass sie für ihn handeln. Das mal in Kurzfassung. Und im Kern, wenn man es auf einen Satz bringen will, dann glaube ich wirklich, und das ist das, was mir so auffällt, wir reden alteuropäisch moralisch und kommen damit aber auch nicht weiter. Ich glaube auch Occupy und vieles andere ist noch in der moralischen Sphäre. Womit wir zu tun haben, ist mit einem Denken, und jetzt bin ich wieder bei der Maschine, das sagt, es ist rational, es ist vernünftig, egoistisch zu sein. Das ist etwas völlig anderes. Das ist eben nicht Aufklärung Immanuel Kant und so weiter, sondern das ist der Mensch, ist der Menschen ein Wolf, wenn man es mal sehr reduziert. Und darum haben die auch kein schlechtes Gewissen. Das ist das, was so auffällig ist. Ich meine, wenn ich da so verantwortlich wäre oder einer von uns für solche Desaster, würden wir ja vielleicht auch vom amerikanischen Kongress oder wo auch immer, vielleicht, gut, man muss dann da durchhalten, aber sie haben keins. Auch in ihren Rechtfertigungsschriften sieht man das ja, wenn sie sehen, bis hin zu so Soziopathen wie de Madoff, was wir da wissen, wie der sich da am Schluss, ich will den jetzt nicht zum, ich will diese Branche, ich will damit sogar die fast ein bisschen entlasten, weil ich glaube, dass die in einer Rationalität drin stecken und damit werden, sind wir wieder bei dem Bild, man wird, sie werden, sag ich mal so, jetzt frag ich sie mal, werden sie, wie werden sie geformt, eher, was glauben sie als Mensch, wenn sie sich jetzt als junger Mensch vorstellen, dadurch, dass ihnen jemand sagt, es ist aber gut, wenn man so ist und es ist richtig und benimm dich und so weiter, oder wenn ihnen jemand und möglichst auch indirekt sagt, das ist vernünftig. Also wenn sie sagen, dadurch ihren eigenen, ich glaube, dass das das Dilemma ist, in dem wir mit dem wir Augenblick zu tun haben. Wir reden von Rationalität, wir reden nicht von Moral und diese Rationalität bekommt etwas Normatives.
Na ja, es geht ja aber noch weiter. Also einer der Aspekte, die man dann nicht übersehen darf bei dem Versuch, den Menschen berechenbarer zu machen, ist ja diese Public Choice Policy. Also quasi, was in Großbritannien ja in großem Maßstab ausprobiert wurde, dass man gesagt hat, man versucht den Menschen vorhersagbarer zu machen in seinem Verhalten, indem man zum einen und anderen damit, dass er egoistisch handelt und ihn dann aber mit Incentives, also mit Anreizen, dazu bringt, so zu handeln, wie es der Designer halt irgendwie möchte, also in diesem Fall der Politiker. Und man sich dann diese Werkzeuge, die es ja da gibt, also man kann Menschen natürlich manipulieren. Das ist nicht so einfach, wie man immer glaubt und ist halt auch tatsächlich möglicherweise widerspruchsvoll und nicht immer so straight forward, wie es funktionieren sollte. Aber der Glaube daran, dass der Mensch halt beeinflussbar ist, durchaus auch im positiven Sinne, in dem man ihm Anreize gibt, der steht ja hinter vielen von solchen politischen Entscheidungen.
Die Anreize bestätigen ja auch die Ego-These.
Genau, also dass man halt einfach sagt, man handelt zu seinem eigenen Vorteil, also formuliert man die Anreize so, dass aus dem Handeln zum eigenen Vorteil ein Handeln im Sinne des großen Ziels nicht zwingend der Allgemeinheit, aber im Sinne des großen Ziels passiert. Also sei es nun, ob das große Ziel ist, irgendwie die Staatsquote zu reduzieren oder irgendwie die Gesundheitskosten zu reduzieren oder was auch immer gerade als das große Ziel definiert wird. Und darauf beschränkt sich Politik ja zum großen Teil.
Genau, das hat sich verselbstständigt. Das ist genau mein Punkt. Sie haben, und das merke ich eben auch, das ist auch eine Veränderung. Ich sage immer nur den Namen Willy Brandt so in den Raum hinein, auch wenn ich den vielleicht etwas idealisiere. Aber sie können mit Incentives, das funktioniert ja ganz gut, dass Leute dann eben nicht mehr so dreckschleudern als Autos fahren. Das kann man alles mit Incentives ja regeln. Aber irgendwo in dem ganzen Spiel muss es irgendwann eine politische Entscheidung geben. Die muss das immer geben. Irgendwann muss einer sagen, ich will das für diese Gesellschaft und das will ich nicht. Und ich glaube, dass das ist, womit wir heute zu tun haben, dass die fehlt. Also das wäre ja bei der Europadebatte so wichtig, dass man sagt, und ich glaube, das ist der Beweis. Fefe liest Kahnemann. Giga Renzer hat, das geht ja in Richtung Behavioral Economics, ziemlich genau gezeigt, dass wenn wir auf dem Weg der Verhaltensökonomie weitergehen, wir im Grunde die Neoklassik oder Neoliberalismus implementieren noch in unser intimes Leben, weil es dann die Frage ist, welche Anreize muss ich setzen, um, was weiß ich, mein Kind im Kindergarten rechtzeitig abholen zu lassen und so weiter. Also das geht schon sehr weit. Selbst das würde ich noch hinnehmen, wenn es irgendwo fast eine Immunisierung von Politik, von solchen Incentives gäbe, was aber sie nicht tut. Da gebe ich ihnen ja völlig recht. Siehe Demoskopie und all solche Sachen. Und sie sagt, das will ich. Ich will ein Europa, das so und so ist. Zum Beispiel ist es etwas, womit man sich sehr unbeliebt macht, bei zum Beispiel der neuen Partei, AfD und vielen Leuten. Ich zitiere das als Beispiel, als Test oft bei Politikern. Das ist jetzt leider nicht so toll. Ergebnisse gewesen, muss ich auch gleich sagen. Willy Brandt, habe ich hier schon mal gesagt, vor der Ansprache an die Deutschen, schwarz-weiß, total charismatisch über die Ostverträge. Liebe Leute, nichts geben wir Preis, was nicht schon längst verloren wäre, aber wir haben ein Ziel. Jetzt stelle ich mir vor, Europa, vielleicht ist das romantisch, aber das wäre politisch. Liebe Deutsche, liebe Leute, ehe es ihr über eure Renten merkt und so weiter, jetzt sagen wir es euch, das Geld ist wahrscheinlich weg. Wir geben aber nichts Preis, was nicht schon verloren wäre, aber wir haben ein Ziel damit. Und dieses Ziel heißt das und das. Und jetzt könnt ihr euch entscheiden, ob ihr es wollt oder nicht. Das wäre für mich auch der Ausweg. Ich glaube gar nicht an so große revolutionäre Auswege. Aber ich glaube, dass Politik, jedenfalls im Augenblick, darum haben wir das Alternativ, was dazu nicht willens ist. Und deshalb auch die Rolle des Bundesverfassungsgerichts immer größer wird, weil sie schließlich an diese...
Die fällen halt noch Entscheidungen.
Ja, genau. Diese Instanz ist dann...
Tun sie aber auch nicht mehr, ne? Nehmen wir die letzte Entscheidung zur Anti-Terror-Datei.
Die fand ich sehr interessant.
Die halt einfach auch keine Entscheidung war, sondern mehr so...
Die wollen einfach in dieser Rolle nicht sein. Die haben halt gesehen, dass sie einfach die einzige Instanz sind.
Das ist komplexer, glaube ich. Ich denke schon, dass sie diese Rolle der ultimativen Entscheidungsinstanz, dass sie die schon haben.
Das wollen sie haben, aber sie wollen nicht die Fortinstanz sein, die alle Entscheidungen trifft, weil die Politik immer...
Ne, ich glaube, dass das Problem tiefer liegt. Ich war ja bei der Verhandlung dabei.
Anti-Terror-Datei.
Anti-Terror-Datei und auch bei verschiedenen anderen Verhandlungen und habe ansonsten ein paar Urteile durchgelesen. Ich glaube, was die Richter da tun als ultimative Entscheidungsinstanz, ist ja etwas, was die Politik vorher tun sollte. Sich nämlich intensiv mit dem Problem zu beschäftigen und zu versuchen, zu gucken, ob es also welche möglichen Folgen, welche Entscheidungsvarianten haben würden. Also tatsächlich irgendwie zu gucken, wenn wir in diese Richtung entscheiden, könnte das passieren. Wenn wir in diese Richtung entscheiden, könnte das passieren. Und dann laden sich Experten zu einem, machen sich ein Bild von der Lage und entscheiden dann halt. Und dieser Prozess, der, sagen wir mal, Wahrheitsfindung mal in Anführungszeichen setzt, der ist ja in der Politik schon lange vorgekommen verdorben. Also es gibt halt quasi, wenn man zum Bundestagsausschuss zum Beispiel war und da vorgetragen hat, es hat halt irgendwie nichts mehr mit tatsächlich dem echten Versuch, irgendwie dem Problem auf den Grund zu kommen zu tun.
Ja doch.
Moment, Moment, so die versuchen halt, die versuchen schon zu verstehen, was das Problem ist und welche Lösungsmöglichkeiten sie haben.
Sie laden dich nicht ein, um irgendwas daraus zu gewinnen, sondern weil wenn sie dich nicht einladen, wäre das anfechtbar, was sie tun. Genau, sondern was sie tun ist, ich erzähl ja immer gerne diese Anekdote, als ich da mal war und begrüßt wurde mit den Worten, schön, dass sie wieder da sind, nachdem wir sie das letzte Mal schon komplett ignoriert haben.
Genau.
Also das ist da der Status.
Und dieser Moment, und lass mich kurz diesen Weg kurz zu Ende führen. Und beim Verfassungsgericht habe ich den Eindruck, dass ich genau diese Art, dass aus einem anderen Grund nicht entschieden wird. Nämlich, weil die einfach die Probleme immer komplexer gemacht werden. Deshalb werden wir also vor eine Situation gestellt, wo Probleme absichtlich so komplex gemacht werden, dass eine rationale Entscheidung quasi nicht mehr möglich ist.
Wie die Russen im Kalten Krieg?
Wie diese Krankenversicherungskarte.
Genau, wie diese Krankenversicherungskarte. Für mich war der entscheidende Moment, wo mich diese Erkenntnis packte, war damals, ich weiß nicht, wir hören uns bestimmt noch dran, als die Zeit den Leunerskandal aufbereitet hat. Da haben die so eine sechsfach Ausfallgrafik gemacht.
Das war super.
Wo sie den Leunerskandal aufgemalt haben als so Kestin diagramm.
Und das war ein Gesamtkunstwerk, den konnte man nicht voll besetzen, wenn man es komplett vor sich hat.
Und es war einfach völlig unmöglich zu sagen, wer ist denn jetzt eigentlich schuld? Also das kann man nur noch aus dem Bauch heraus entscheiden. Diese, was wir haben mit diesem vorhin besprochen haben, diese Ablösung von Kausalitäten oder des Versuchs des intellektuellen Ergründens von Ursachen und das Abschätzen von möglichen Wirkungen durch eine statistische Analyse. Das wäre das, was wir jetzt tun. Wir versuchen nicht mehr zu verstehen, warum ist es so. Sondern wir gucken irgendwie nach Benchmarks, wir versuchen irgendwie Statistiken zu finden, wir versuchen irgendwie möglichst viele Daten zu kriegen, um daraus halt Schlüsse zu ziehen. Und daraus dann irgendeine Art von Entscheidungen zu fällen. Und was dabei halt völlig untergeht, ist halt immer die Frage, was wollen wir denn eigentlich erreichen? Welche Welt wollen wir denn? Was ist dann eigentlich unser gesellschaftliches Ziel? Was ist dann eigentlich der, sozusagen der, ja, genau was Willy Brandt sagte, was wollen wir denn? So völlig unabhängig, warum wir das wollen.
Und das hat mich übrigens richtig gestört beim Verfassungsgerät, muss ich sagen, bei den letzten Entscheidungen. Gerade bei dieser, bei den, als sie dann mit den ökonomischen Argumentationen anfingen. Ja, aber das würde die Eurozone gefährden. Weil die Märkte haben schon gegen uns gewettet. Ja und dafür gehe ich nicht zum Verfassungsgericht, um zu erfahren, was die Märkte gewettet haben. Das geht mir total, geht mir total an mir vorbei. Ich möchte gern, dass ihr das Richtige entscheidet, nicht das, was ihr glaubt, was der Markt möchte. Ich muss ja noch zwei, drei Sachen nachtragen, die ich mir hier notiert habe. Also erstens die Sache mit Europa und der Moral. Dazu möchte ich gern noch sagen, dass der Vorwurf im Moment ja gerne gebracht wird gegenüber den Griechen oder auch gegenüber uns. Wir leben über unsere Verhältnisse. Und das ist ein moralischer Vorwurf. Das ist kein rationaler Vorwurf, sondern es ist moralisch. Also das funktioniert auch noch. Dann möchte ich gern noch anmerken, dass wir seit vielen Jahren versuchen, mit der Politik gegen die Märkte zu führen. Also der War on Drugs zum Beispiel, die Drogenprohibition, das ist seit vielen Jahren der Versuch, gegen den Markt zu agieren. Das funktioniert einfach nicht. Also insofern finde ich das nicht verwunderlich.
Bei Steuerhinterziehung geht es jetzt.
Aber diese Idee, dass wir jetzt kommen und sagen, na gut, dann machen wir das wie im Kalten Krieg, das ist eine Verzweiflungstat aus meiner Sicht. Weil wir haben die anderen, direkteren Sachen versucht.
Es ist ja keine bewusste Entscheidung. Ich glaube, es ist schon stärker, als nur so jetzt machen wir das, weil das andere nicht funktioniert hat. Sondern wir können ja diesen, wir neigen dazu, diese Ego-Story als eindimensional zu sehen. Wir können es immer von der anderen Seite sehen. Und zwar sozusagen, was sie positiv herbringt oder wohin es dann führt. Also das bedeutet ja, wenn ich der Meinung bin und da sind wir nämlich jetzt auch bei den modernen Datenkraken, muss ich eigentlich nur die Präferenzen des Menschen kennen. Also ich muss eigentlich nur wissen, was will er, wenn ich jetzt sozusagen einen Markt um ihn herum konstruiere. Und ich brauche auch nicht mehr zu wissen, woher das kommt und so weiter. Also das ist diese Frage der Präferenz, dass Google mir sagt, ist ja nett und Amazon und all das, das brauche ich hier gar nicht auszuführen. Das Problem ist nur. Und das ist eine Debatte, die interessanterweise Amerika geführt wird. Und in Deutschland noch nicht, obwohl es in Europa gerade passiert. Wenn alles like it wird und Präferenz wird. Und das ist ja, das ist nämlich Max Planck Satz. Wenn die tot sind, die das andere gar nicht mehr kennen, werden wir mal sehen, was dann passiert. Was es dann eigentlich mit Dingen für diesen Augenblick keinen Markt gibt. Also nehmen wir mal an Rechtsfragen. Es könnte doch sein, dass es für bestimmte, die wir für ewig halten, haben wir ja oft genug in der Geschichte erlebt, plötzlich ändert sich das. Ein imaginäres Baby-Sit findet bestimmte Sachen des Rechts. Selbstbestimmung, Gleichberechtigung. Gibt es halt, was ist eigentlich, das ist ja auch nur eine Präferenz der Gesellschaft. Der Herr Borbitt schreibt ja, die Wahlen sind da nur noch da für irgendwas. Es geht dann um so eine richtig ständig ermittelte Präferenz. Und in Europa haben wir das erlebt. Und da bin ich nämlich jetzt bei dem Beispiel, das sie aus dem Bundestag bringen. Ich glaube schon, dass da, muss ich wirklich sagen, dass da viele verstehen wollen und selber in diesem System sind. Und auch die Merkel ist jemand, die, glaube ich, sehr das Problem ist. Während wir das noch verstehen wollen, brechen wir bereits aufgrund von Marktpräferenzen das Recht. Das ist für mich ja fast schlimmer als die Krise, als dieses Geld bei dieser Krise. Dass man einfach, ob man das jetzt ein gutes Recht findet oder ein schlechtes, vom Maastricht-Vertrag angefangen, von vielen anderen Dingen, dass man einfach, oder von dieser Frage des Pläbisziets bei den Griechen oder dass das Bundesverfassungsgericht dreimal sagte, bitte Demokratie, Demokratie. Das finde ich so.
Unser Wahlrecht.
Wenn Recht dann nur noch ein Marktbestandteil ist, wie ein Eis oder wie ein Ding, das ist nicht apokalyptisch gesprochen, sondern dafür haben wir Indizien in Europa gehabt. Und da ist Politik umso wichtiger. Das Verfassungsgericht kann das nicht allein. Ich habe das gesehen mit einem Richter aus dem anderen Senat, während diese Frage war es ESM. Und da hat die Politik, was wir heute schon wieder vergessen haben, dauernd solche Drohungen ausgegeben, wenn die das aber nicht beschließen und so weiter, wenn die dann zerstören die Europapolitik. Und diese Leute sind ja total verschwiegen und diskret. Aber man merkte dann schon, dass die natürlich diesen Druck, der da auf ihn lastete, auch diesen moralischen Druck total spürten. Und da dachte ich mir, es ist nicht gut, wenn ein Gemeinwesen am Ende, die haben jetzt nicht geschwitzt oder so, aber von der fast Nervenzustand, von dem Nervenkostüm von so ein paar Richtern abhängt, die dann die allerletzte Instanz sind für Entscheidungen, die politisch nicht mehr ausgemendet werden können, dann wird es einem doch etwas mulmig. Und das ist der Preis dessen, was wir zahlen für eine Politik, die nicht mehr sagt, was sie will. Denn das sagt sie ja express. Das werb ich sie nicht. Das ist ja die neue asymmetrische Wedermobilisierung alters.
Aufsichtlich nicht. Die wollen ja niemanden verschrecken bei den Wedern.
Exakt. Bloß kein Thema, dass die Weder der Gegenseite zur Wahlordnung ringen könnte. Was dazu führt, dass wir in dem Zustand sind, haben wir das letzte Mal schon besprochen, in dem wir sind. Jetzt frag ich mich immer, wo ist die Instanz, an die man sich wenden kann. Öffentlichkeit? Also da bin ich jetzt, ich bin jetzt nicht der Meinung, dass wir Grund haben, uns so zu rühmen, wie Superöffentlichkeit im Augenblick funktioniert. Gerade in der Euro-Krise.
Ich hab das lustigerweise als einen Punkt notiert, für ein Beispiel dafür, wo sich der Mensch, der Maschine unterordnet, Liquid Feedback, was ja eigentlich die große Hoffnung der Piranenpartei ist. Aber man kann es auch aus dem anderen Winkel betrachten, dass der Mensch nur noch Teilnehmer ist in dem großen Maschinenregelwerk. Genau.
Ein permanentes Plebiscit, kann man genauso sehen.
Ja, ganz furchtbar.
Die interessante Frage dabei ist ja am Ende, wenn die Frage des Ziels von Politik, der ja ausgewichen wird, also wir sozusagen keine, also am Ende, wenn wir jetzt sonst, der Wahlkampf ist gerade wieder ein schönes Beispiel dafür, am Ende reden wir sozusagen nur noch von so abstrakten, ganz vagen Werten. Also so irgendwie, also es gibt so Parteien, die haben...
So und Europa, so während sozusagen in Griechenland und in Spanien und so die jungen Leute so fast am Mock laufen.
Wisst ihr, was mich wirklich irritiert hat, also ich guck mir ja immer diese Neusprechvorträge an zum Kongress und die haben letztes Mal den Punkt gemacht, dass den Nazis die Adjektive ausgegangen sind, weil sie einfach von vornherein immer die ultimative, furchtbare Sachen an die Wand geschrieben haben und dann mussten sie das aber noch steigern, weil es muss ja schlimmer sein als gestern und das ist glaube ich, was uns als nächstes kommen wird, da ist es dann, im Grunde ist es ja schon nicht mehr steigerbar, was wir jetzt haben, die Eurozone ist am abnippeln.
Deswegen ist die Krise doch jetzt vorbei. Das ist genau der Grund, die Krise ist deswegen vorbei. Weil wir keine Laute mehr haben.
Weil es halt irgendwie nicht mehr steigerungsfähig ist. Und jetzt sind wir wieder bei dem Spiel. Und ich bin sehr gerne bereit, wenn man mir sagt, ich übertreibe, aber ich wüsste gerne, wenn das jetzt soweit ist, ist jetzt das Spiel eigentlich vorbei? Jetzt sagt das der und was passiert jetzt als nächstes? Jetzt holt man jemand, passiert nämlich immer dann jemand wie Soros aus der Versenkung oder einen anderen Tycoon. Ja, der dann plötzlich sagt, Eurozone fliegt auseinander oder so. Sie können das Spiel unendlich, selbst deren, wenn Soros, der war vor drei Wochen in allen Medien, hat da wieder ein Interview, ein Buch und was weiß ich. Und dann ist doch immer die Frage, selbst der, das wird ja dann so gelesen, ist das die Einschätzung, dass er selber ein Händler, obwohl er behauptet, er sei es nicht mehr, hat eigene Interessen und so weiter. Und es gibt hunderte Soros, natürlich tausend andere, jeder hat irgendwelche Interessen. Das Spiel ist eben, das ist das Wesen dieses Spiels, es ist natürlich nicht vorbei.
Es kann auch niemand beenden, das Spiel, weil es keinen Spieldatter gibt.
Weil es keine Entscheidung... Ich finde, das ist nicht sozusagen billig gewesen, wenn man sich aufregte. Manchmal regt man sich über billige. Aber dieser Satz, there is no alternative und der Vergleichssatz mit der marktkonformen Demokratie, das sind wirklich Schlüsselbegriffe. Das ist die Wahrheit gewesen. Da hat jemand mal die Wahrheit gesagt.
Sind wir auch gleich aufgesprungen und haben unseren Podcast noch nicht genannt?
Ich gucke mir gerade ein bisschen an, was gibt es denn eigentlich noch an Gesellschaftsidealen? Was sind denn die Idealvorstellungen, die noch übrig geblieben sind? Die einzigen, die noch eine explizite ideologische Gesellschaftsvorstellung haben, sind interessanterweise die Chinesen. Die haben dieses Idealbild der harmonischen Gesellschaft. Die harmonische Gesellschaft ist, soweit ich es verstanden habe, ich bin gerade erst dabei, es noch richtig anzugucken, ist der Versuch, eine otataristische Ethik zum Gesellschaftsmodell zu erheben. Das heißt, das größtmögliche Glück für die größtmögliche Zahl. Wenn es dabei einer kleinen Zahl nicht so super geht, ist es, wenn sich so ein statistisches Mittel herausmittelt, nicht so schlimm. Das ist die Ideologie dahinter. Das ist relativ straightforward. Damit kann man eben auch mal irgendwo einen 3-Schluchten-Damm hinbauen und irgendwie 500.000 Leute evakuieren. Wenn damit Strom für 50 Millionen geliefert wird, dann ist das okay. Das ist aus der sozialistischen Politikethik abgeleitet. Im Endeffekt ist das immerhin ein Ansatz, der natürlich vollständig inkompatibel ist der individualistischen europäischen Traditionen. Und der noch viel individualistischeren amerikanischen Traditionen hat. Während Europa, wenn man das mal als Spektrum betrachtet, ist Europa da irgendwo in der Mitte. Da haben dann die Amerikaner auf der einen Seite mit dem extrem Heinrent egoistischen Individualismus und die Chinesen auf der anderen Seite, die sagen, hauptsache es geht unseren 1,5 Milliarden Leuten im Schnitt jedes Jahr ein bisschen besser. Und wenn es 5 Millionen Leuten schlechter geht oder die dabei starben, Herrgott Pech gehabt. Und die Europäer sind sozusagen ein bisschen in der Mitte und sagen, wir wollen eine Gesellschaft als ideal haben. Also nicht nur wie einen utilitaristischen Betrachtung, sondern eben auch das Individuum mit seinen Menschenrechten und so weiter und so fort. Und wenn man sich aber anguckt, wie die Politik sich bewegt in Europa, dann ist sie ja zunehmend ahnungslos, was ihre eigentlichen Ziele sind. Also es gibt eigentlich keinen Überbau mehr. Also keinen ideologischen Überbau, der halt über wir verteidigen uns ein bisschen gegen irgendwie das amerikanische Modell und wir wollen aber auch keinen Kommunismus haben. Und dazwischen wabert das eigentlich nur noch hin und her.
Naja, nee. Also ich finde das interessant, denn immer wenn du nicht weißt, wie es weitergeht, das billigste Rangmuster, das billigste Gerüst, an dem du dich hantieren kannst, ist, konsistent zu früheren Aktionen zu sein.
Stabilität.
Und das ist auch wirklich das einzige, wie heute noch argumentiert wird. Das wird ja nicht gesagt, wir tun es jetzt, damit es besser wird, sondern wir...
Damit es nicht anders wird.
Wir müssen es jetzt tun, weil wir das schon immer gemacht haben und es funktioniert. Alle Argumente, die es so gibt für diese Wirtschaftsrettung und das müssen wir so machen, denn das haben wir da unterprobiert und es hat funktioniert. Stimmt zwar nicht, aber das ist nicht der Punkt an der Stelle. Weil es ein anderes Argument gibt es nicht mehr.
Auf der Mikroebene sind sie ja gar nicht. Also Frau Merkel ist jetzt ja nicht konsistent zu ihren früheren Positionen.
Nein, im Gegenteil. Aber das ist... Interessanterweise stört das bei der Merkel niemand.
Ich glaube, wenn man es auf... Ich liebe das mit der Maschine einfach. Ich glaube, dass das eine Metapher ist für die Gegenwart. Die Deutschen haben in der Kanzlerin Frau Merkel jemanden, und das ist ja auch, vielleicht will man das, wenn man das will, muss man es aber auch dann die Folgen in Kauf nehmen, die in einer nicht mehr gut funktionierenden Maschine sie repariert. Das ist so jemand, der ständig... Viele wollen aber, dass die Maschine abgestellt wird. Vielleicht umgebaut wird oder auch abgestellt wird. Dass sie mal geöffnet wird, dass man rauskommen kann. Und das finde ich auch eine sehr wünschenswerte Forderung. Und jetzt kommen wir zu dem, was Frank Rieger gerade sagte. Wir werden jetzt ja sehen, was Helmut Schmidt in seinem neuen China-Buch über das Gesellschaftsmodell, das er ja gut findet, uns erklärt. Aber es ist ja nicht unseres. Und das wäre ja Europa. Ständig lesen wir, also dieser schreckliche, absurd Begriff Globalisierung, der für alles, der lächerlichste Begriff in meinen Augen überhaupt, weil er nichts erklärt. Ob ich jetzt Globalisierung sage oder Imperialismus oder was auch immer, das ist der Verkennungsgewinn sehr gering. Europa steht in der Mitte zwischen Amerika und China, hat eine völlig andere Geschichte und hat vor allen Dingen eine kooperative, unter vielen Kämpfen diese kooperative Idee geboren. Das war Europa. Und jetzt frage ich mich eben, warum es so schwer ist zu sagen, gerade wenn man immer behauptet, unseren Kindern soll es besser gehen. Es wird der Tag kommen, wo zum Beispiel die Chinesen sich dieses Modell ganz genau angucken. Wäre so eine These. Es wird eine Tag kommen, wo dieses funktionierende kooperative Modell, wie es die Soziale Marktwirtschaft mal war, tatsächlich auch ein Exportschlager wird. Dafür könnten wir Europa eine Alternative, there is an alternative bieten. Und in meinen Augen geht es sehr weit. Ich weiß, dass man dafür dann belächelt wird. Bei mir geht es bis zu einer eigenen Suchmaschine. Das geht bis zu, also im digitalen Zeitalter, bis zu eigenen Rating Agenturen und so weiter. Aber muss ja vielleicht nicht so präzise sein. Aber diese Idee einer europäischen Vision, dass wir, das kostet uns natürlich auch was erst mal. Das ist so, das können wir nicht bestreiten. Aber es kostet uns ja auch im Zerfall schon was. Warum dann nicht in der Konstruktion von etwas Neuem? Der Zerfall der Maschine kostet uns genauso viel, dass man sagt, okay, wir werden vielleicht jetzt nicht mit den Chinesen Schritt halten können, was den Arbeitsmarkt angeht und was auch immer. Aber wir können sicher sein, dass wir ein humanes Modell haben, das dann später für viele interessant werden könnte. Und zwar Europa, ganz Europa. Das wäre eine politische Forderung. Wenn ich das kurz sagen darf, damit man die Realität dagegen leuchtet, warum ich das sage, wenn Sie das naiv finden, dann nenne ich jetzt auch den Namen, weil er hat so einen großen Kreis gesagt, der ja wirklich dieser Sache sich sehr bewusst, Präsident des Europäischen Parlaments, Schulz, hat die Geschichte erzählt, dass die wahren Mächtigen in Brüssel, die sogenannten, ich glaube, sie heißen Generaldirektoren sind. Das ist wie ein Kafka-Schloss, das sind Beamte, die direkt von dem Kabinett, also direkt von dem Regierungschef, denn das Parlament hat da ja bisher keine Macht. So, das sind die, die eigentlich die Macht haben und die die eigentlichen Entscheidungen treffen. Und jetzt sagt Schulz, der seit 20 Jahren, glaube ich, oder 25 Jahren im Europäischen Parlament ist, und vor ein paar Monaten habe ich zum ersten Mal einen von denen gesehen, bei einem Empfang irgendwo. Und dann sagte der auch noch zu ihm, was tun sie denn hier? Also das so als Implement einer Quaskafka-Esken. Ich hoffe, ich habe jetzt keine, aber er hat es wirklich vor vielen Leuten erzählt. Das ist, ich meine, das ist jetzt das Gegenbild. Ein System, das bis in die Fragen, ein total bürokratisches System in seinem Herzen, das ist Brüssel, und ein zerfallendes Europa. Und das Gegenbeispiel wäre diese Idee, hört zu, es dauert vielleicht zwei oder drei Generationen, aber wir haben Erfahrung mit Kooperation, weil wir uns so oft die Köpfe eingeschlagen haben. Und so oft wirtschaftskriege geführt haben und was auch immer. Und so oft die soziale Marktwirtschaft nicht als Chance gesehen haben, sondern als Belastung. Und jetzt können wir sie wieder als Chance sehen. Das wäre das, was ich, mehr wenig würde ich gar nicht wollen, von einer visionären Politik.
Naja, also ich muss doch mal dagegen.
Ja, jetzt kommen sie mal dagegen.
Und einen Witz hinsetzen, dann können sie sofort dagegen gehen.
Auch gegen die Suchmaschine.
Ja, frag hat sicher recht, aber ich möchte eine Sache noch kurz sagen. Der Egoismus ist doch eigentlich die Antithese zur Demokratie, oder nicht? Die Demokratie setzt doch aus. Das geht doch davon aus.
Das finde ich nicht.
Wieso? Man sagt doch, das Volk als souverän, also man betreibt es als Gruppe, kooperative Gruppe von Leuten, die eben nicht nur für ihr eigenes Ziel, in meinen Augen ist das ein Widerspruch.
Ja, es ist dann ein Widerspruch, wenn man sagt, es ist vernünftig, egoistisch zu sein. Aber wir können den Menschen ja nicht ändern. Das Genie dieser modernen Welt, also im Guten, ist ja, dass es ihr gelingt, egoistische Interessen, dann tatsächlich, dafür ist ja Demokratie entstanden, tatsächlich eine Richtung zu geben, die dann, damit ist auch viel Schindbluder getrieben worden, das darf man ja nicht vergessen. Es hat ja einen Grund, das muss man vielleicht mal wirklich deuten, es hat ja einen Grund, dass diese Idee so stark wurde, weil man sah, die Nazis und auf der anderen Seite die Kommunisten haben das missbraucht und haben gesagt, wir wissen besser, was für dich gut ist, als du selber. Das war der Kern, sozusagen der moralische Kern des Arguments. Nur leben wir jetzt in einer neuen Welt und ich glaube schon, dass wenn man sagt, es ist vernünftig, sondern wenn man sagt, ja es gehört zum Menschen dazu, dass er natürlich sehr klar auch egoistisch ist. Damit kann man doch leben. Damit kann man doch eine Gesellschaft und auch eine Demokratie machen. Wir sind es ja auch.
Ich glaube, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt dabei, ist, dass die...
Nur es zu einem System zu machen.
Das ist eher natürlich klar. Genau da kommen wir zum Kern der Sache, nämlich dass die postideologische Präsentation, also das, was wir sozusagen betrachten als gegeben, eben genau dieses wir sind doch sowieso nur alle Egoisten und die Ideologien, die uns versucht haben, was anderes einzureden, also sprich halt insbesondere Sozialismus, Kommunismus oder auch die Nazis, die ja sozusagen einen kollektivistischen Anspruch haben, die sind ja gescheitert und aus diesem Scheitern wird unmittelbar abgeleitet, dass halt kooperative Ansätze per se auch scheitern müssen. So und dabei werden natürlich verschiedene Dinge übersehen. Also zum Beispiel der Kritikpunkt an diesem europäischen Großding ist, dass bisher der, also aus meiner Sicht, dass bisher der Beweis, dass es möglich ist, eine kooperative Struktur dieser Größe aufzubauen, noch nicht angetreten wurde. Weil alle anderen Länder, die eine ähnliche Größe haben und nicht zentralistisch regiert sind, sind federale Systeme. Das heißt also, wo die kooperativen Entitäten, nämlich sprich die einzelnen Länder, überschaubar groß sind. So und denke, dass das ein Mechanismus, der in dieser europäischen Idee übersehen wird. Dass also einfach dieses, wir sind alle Europäer, klingt ja erstmal toll, geht uns neunter und so, aber wir sprechen einfach mal eine andere Sprache. Wir haben unterschiedliche Kulturen, wir haben unterschiedliche Rechtskulturen. Wir wissen nicht mal, also wenn man sich zum Beispiel die Verhandlungen vom Europäischen Gerichtshof anguckt, die sind mit nichts zu vergleichen mit dem Verfassungsgericht. Die sind völlig andere, das kommt irgendwie aus dem englischen Handelsrecht, was die da fahren. Da fühlt man sich irgendwie mit seinen Menschenrechten und seinen Vorstellungen von irgendwie deutschem Verfassungsrecht überhaupt in keiner Weise aufgehoben. Und ich denke, dass dieses Übertreiben, dieses irgendwie, wir wollen eine zentralistische Großentität schaffen, weil die profitabler ist und die halt Entscheidungen für ganz Europa trifft in allen kleinen Bereichen, dass dieses Übertreiben...
Das war nicht meine Idee.
Das will auch glaube ich keiner. Das ist nur konsistent. Das folgt aus den Sachen, auf die wir uns schon kommetgetan haben. Und so funktioniert unsere Politik.
Das ist ja genau das, da kommt es dann zu Bananenverordnungen und so etwas. Was ich ja meine, ist etwas, das ist gar nicht so groß. Das ist einfach, wenn man jetzt vom Institutionellen absieht, dass zum Beispiel, wäre super, die gesamte Silicon Valley ist das Ergebnis von Subventionen durch den Staat. Auch der Neoliberalismus. Militär, Militär. Wieso nicht mal so eine Vision? Es muss ja nicht die Mondlandung sein. Es könnte ja zum Beispiel auch ein europäisches Silicon Valley sein. Oder was auch richtig massiv. Aber um ganz konkret zu sagen, die Punkt ist, es geht ja nur um ein paar Übertragungen von Souveränitätsrechten zum Beispiel nach Brüssel. Und zwar auf der Ebene, wo es wirklich interessant wird. Die es dann dazu führen könnte, dass tatsächlich ein allgemeines, ich glaube, das ist nämlich schon ziemlich weit. Wenn Sie heute in allen Ländern fragen würden, finden Sie es bedrohlich, dass die jungen Leute arbeitslos sind? Würden Sie bei der Frage zum Beispiel, jetzt ist es natürlich sehr allgemein, da würden Sie auch viel, und kann man es dagegen tun, ich glaube, da würde man schon viel auslösen können. Also es geht um solche Fragen, das sind nicht ganz kleine Schritte. Wir werden es nächstes Jahr erleben. Da wird zum ersten Mal ja, jetzt geht es um den Barroso-Nachfolger, zum ersten Mal einen europäischen Wahlkampf geben. Und dann werden wir ja sehen, wer dann sozusagen kandidiert und ob es dann eine europäische Öffentlichkeit gibt. Aber mir reicht es ja schon, wenn diese Idee einer There-is-an-alternative, wenn die einfach viel stärker im politischen Diskurs da wäre und damit auch das Risiko, dass damit nicht auf Nummer sicher geht, nicht auf Demoskopie so sehr achten, sondern zu sagen, okay, und jetzt träumen wir mal. Vielleicht kann man ja das sagen und das nicht dem Bundespräsidenten überlassen, sondern jemand, der operativ tätig ist.
Spannenderweise war die Linkspartei ja immer die Einzigen, die sich nicht so von den Fokusgruppen haben lenken lassen, sondern die auch mal so eine eigene Sache geäußert haben.
Vorschlag, fünf Minuten Kaffeepause. Also einer der wesentlichen Treiber für Politik heutzutage ist ja der der Versuch erfolgreich auszusehen und einer der Dinge, die da immer weit vorne sind, ist natürlich Wirtschaft, die also groß, stark und mächtig sein sollte. Und wenn man sich so die deutsche Politik anguckt, dann war ja so zu den Zeiten des Start-up-Booms des ersten und des ersten Aktienbooms mit der Telekom an der Börse und so, da haben die immer versucht, sich da irgendwie ranzuhängen. Und also den, gerade so Roland Koch und so, der dann selbst bei so Versagerfirmen wie Biodata meinte, die sind doch ganz innovativ und neu aus.
Das konntest du dir jetzt nicht verknüpfen.
Nein, Entschuldigung. Die Kombination von Roland Koch und Biodata, Entschuldigung, da kann man eigentlich fast nichts mehr sagen dazu. Jedenfalls die Inspiration dafür ist natürlich die Silicon Valley. Und das Silicon Valley ist ja nicht nur ein relativ einzigartiger Soziokosmos von Venture-Kapitalisten und Firmen, die sich da bilden und Leuten, die willens sind, da zu arbeiten unter den dortigen Bedingungen, sondern...
Ich soll vielleicht kurz sagen, wer noch nie da war, das Silicon Valley ist in der Wüste. Da gibt es nichts, was attraktiv wäre. Es ist immer scheiße warm. Man braucht Klimaanlage im Auto und im Gebäude. Das ist total unattraktiv. Ich würde da nie arbeiten wollen. Ich bin da extra mal hingefahren, um mir das anzugucken. Unmögliche Arbeitsumgebung, da würde auch keiner wohnen wollen. Inzwischen ist der Wohnpreis da so hoch, dass es sich selbst die Leute, die da arbeiten, im Grunde nicht leisten können. Aber historisch gesehen wollte da niemand arbeiten. Kalifornien selbst heißt ja irgendwie Ofen oder so auf Mexikanisch, Spanisch halt. Also ganz unattraktive Gegend, dass da überhaupt Ansiedlung gibt, liegt daran, dass da große Navy-Basen waren. Das heißt, das Militär hat einfach gesagt, wir brauchen hier mehr Know-how. Also pumpen wir da jetzt mal Steuergelder rein und gründen hier mal so ein Soziotop. Das hat dieser ganze Mythos von wegen Entrepreneurship und die ganzen...
Aus der Garage.
Ja, alles Bullshit. Das ist alles gezahlt mit Steuergeldern und dementsprechend das uns als Vorbild immer vorzuhalten, hier von wegen so läuft das, wenn man sich selbst organisiert. Alles Unsinn, lasst euch da nicht verarschen. Aber...
Aber wichtig an diesem slicken Valley ist ja der Einfluss, den es auch außerhalb des politischen Raums hat, eben bedingt durch diese, was man irgendwie so schön kalifornische Ideologie nennt, also dieses möglichst wenig regulieren, möglichst viel Innovation fördern, durchaus auch mit staatlichen Geldern, dafür sorgen, dass halt irgendwie man im Zweifel schnell ist, also dass halt irgendwie Firmen schnell gegründet, schnell wieder gekillt werden können und dafür sorgen, dass Investoren möglichst viel Freibach machen können. Und der wichtige Teil, dass sich jeder eben als Teil des Marktes sieht, also dass der eigene Marktwert, also die eigenen Ideen, das eigene Know-how in einem Markt unterwegs sind und sich also in einem Markt bewegen. Und interessant daran ist eben, dass ein Teil der Silicon-Welle-Kultur, also jetzt nicht so sehr die HP-Ecke, sondern mehr so die Apple-Ecke, kommt ja eigentlich auch aus der Hippie-Bewegung. Also von Leuten, die halt so gesagt haben, also mit dem Staat wollen wir eigentlich nichts zu tun haben, weil der Staat sind die Leute, die den Vietnamkrieg angefangen haben, das sind die Leute mit den Gewehren, das sind die Leute, die irgendwie auf den Campus irgendwie Studenten erschossen haben. Und sondern wir wollen möglichst ohne Staat.
Übrigens noch eine Sache, die Idee, dass Kalifornien besonders wenig reguliert wäre, ist auch das Gegenteil der Wahrheit. Also wenn man in Amerika Auto fährt, dann oder überhaupt im Supermarkt ist, dann findet man immer wieder irgendwo das State of California, wir müssen jetzt reinschreiben, dass hier irgendwas drin ist, was wir können nicht ausschließen, dass das schlecht für wiener Mütter ist. Kalifornien ist berühmt dafür in Amerika, dass es die meisten sinnlosen Regulierungen hat. Alles so hippie Scheiße. Also nichts an diesem Mythos stimmt.
Als ich das erste Mal Kalifornien geflogen bin, hat der Pilot im Flugzeug bei der Landung gesagt, welcome to the People's Republic of California.
So sieht es aus. Die haben nämlich so ein Plebizid da, was tatsächlich bindend ist. Und wenn die Medien kommen und irgendwie den Blei bringt euch alle um an die Wand malt, dann gibt es halt schnell mal ein Plebizid, was sagt, wir müssen überall Warn-Labels draufkleben, dass da Blei drin sein könnte.
Gut, bei Blei ist er tatsächlich auch gerechteilig. Ja, natürlich.
Aber also dieses Label ist wirklich auf allem drauf. Ja, also ich meine, gut, Amerika ist eben ein bisschen eigen. Ich hab da mal Salz gesehen, wo drauf stand auf der Packung, Fett-Free. Da hast du keine Frage mehr, es ist halt Amerika. Aber also diese Bleiwarnung ist wirklich auffällig. Und die kommt halt aus Kalifornien.
Gut, aber was mich ja mehr interessiert, ist mir der ideengeschichtliche Aspekt dabei, nämlich dass diese Transferleistung von wir wollen mit dem Staat nichts zu tun haben, weil der mischt sich in unser Leben ein, dafür bietet uns das Kiffen und irgendwie mischt sich ansonsten ein, ist halt störend irgendwie bei der freien Entwicklung des Individuums und des eigenen Hedonismus.
Hat auch ein sehr konstruktivistisches Anteil, dass man sagt, wir bauen uns hier unser eigenes Biotop.
Genau, hin zu dem ur-libertären, aber extrem kapitalistischen Modell, dass man sagt, okay, wir wollen den Staat weghaben und zwar aus allem, also möglichst wenig Steuern zahlen, möglichst wenig Dinge, es soll möglichst alles privat organisiert sein. Und während die europäische Sommerhippie-Bewegung hat ja eher noch so einen kommunerhaften linken, dem Sozialismus eher angenäherten ideologischen Hintergrund, wenn sie überhaupt einen hatten, also viele von denen bezeichneten sich als apolitisch, während es in den USA dann halt, als die sich dann anfingen, sich mal wieder die Haare zu schneiden und zu waschen und irgendwie arbeiten zu gehen, wurde es dann gleich brutal. Also es ging dann gleich hin zu irgendwie, ja, sag mal so Arschloch-CEOs wie Steve Jobs, die halt einfach irgendwie die Leute schon riegelt haben, wie nur irgendwas, aber trotzdem diesen Hippie-Selbstverwirklichungs- ethos irgendwie hochgehalten haben. Diese interessante Kombination, dass die Leute, die da wichtig sind, in diesem, also auch die Community und diese Studentenbewegungen und so, die da entstanden sind, dass deren Staatsferne eben nicht aus der super konservativen Ecke kommt, sondern eben aus einer, wir haben mit dem, oder unsere Eltern haben mit dem Staat schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht, Ecke.
Wobei ich glaube, ein Großteil davon ist auch wieder diese Konsistenzfalle, dass man einfach nicht weiß, wo es hingeht und dann hält man sich eben da fest, auch mit wenig Staat sind wir an anderer Stelle ganz gut gefahren. Ich glaube, das ist eine der größten Gefahren, die wir so haben in unserer Gesellschaft. Dass wir uns nicht daran orientieren, wo wir eigentlich hinwollen, sondern dass wir uns ein Konsistenz festhalten.
Der Punkt ist ja, die kalifornische Ideologie will ja tatsächlich irgendwo hin. Also es geht ja immer um es besser machen. Also tatsächlich immer...
Ja, aber das basiert ja nicht auf Fakten, sondern da wird einfach behauptet, die Privatwirtschaft kann es besser als der Staat.
Also ich, wenn ich mal meinen Angle, meine Perspektive wäre, nochmal, ich glaube wir reden nicht mehr wie im 20. Jahrhundert davon, dass eine Ideologie durch Bücher, Traktate, Manifeste, Parteien entsteht, sondern ich sag's nochmal in der Verkürzung durch die Maschine. Und die Verschmelzung zwischen Gegenkultur, Counterculture und Silicon Valley ist wahrscheinlich, ohne die wäre es zu dieser Verschmelzung nie gekommen. Das ist ein aufregender, viel dokumentierter Fall. 1962 begann die erste Studenten richtig massive Protest. Ich beschreibe das ja in Berkeley, wo die sich Lochkarten umhängten und sagten, ich bin ein Mensch, bitte, das stand doch immer auf den Lochkarten drauf, bitte nicht verunstalten, bitte nicht dicken. Bitte nicht lochen, bitte nicht lochen, ja. Und da gab es diese berühmte Rede, die auch bei YouTube noch zu sehen ist, wir wollen sinngemäß, wir wollen nicht ins Innere der Maschine. Hatte auch sehr viel mit Vietnam und eine. Und dann passierte irgendwas, das ist ja vielfach beschrieben, passierte irgendwas, Ende der 60er Jahren schon, da gibt es Namen wie Stuart Brandt und so, jedenfalls die Gegenkultur, die digitale Kultur verschmolzen. Auch Leute wie übrigens, wie dieser, ich kenne ihn ganz gut auch, viele kennen ihn ja, John Brockman. Das ist ja interessant wegen Ideengeschichte. Der kommt aus der Andy Warhol-Ecke. Der war einer der und wie Stuart Brandt ja zum Teil auch. Das war genau dieses New York, ehe er dann erkannte Moment, hier gibt es neue, die fanden das auch sehr partizipativ. Eben genau kooperativ. Das waren ja auch die frühesten Hacker, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Und das steckt ja als Erbe, als DNA noch bis heute drin. Dass die ganzen Konflikte, die wir heute haben, bis hin zum Leistungsschutzrecht und was auch immer, haben ja damit zu tun. Und über diese Verschmelzung, ich glaube, dass sie im Kern den Neoliberalismus hervorgebracht hat. Ich glaube nicht, dass der jetzt irgendwie so über die Welt kam, aus Chicago als Abart des Neoklassik, sondern ich glaube, dass man sich angucken muss, wie zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt der 70er Jahre Counterculture in Kalifornien, digitale Kultur und, und das ist eben entscheidend, die Wall Street, sozusagen diese drei sich sozusagen verschmolzen. Man muss nicht so weit gehen, dass dann zu nennen, dass dann am Ende so eine Art Cyborg entstanden ist, der, ich meine, wenn man das sieht, was Kevin Kelly, sie kennen ja all diese Namen, was die, das waren ja Utopien, Sondergleichen, die aber alle immer sagten, das, was wir predigen, verwirklicht sich durch die Maschine. Ihr werdet das, wenn man bei Kevin Kelly nachliest. Es ist ja nicht so, dass er sagt, wenn wir das und das jetzt machen und so, wie im 19. Jahrhundert und diese Gesetze erlassen und das und das machen, nein, sondern es war immer, wenn wir dann alle in der Maschine sind und sie vernetzen, wird das und das möglich sein. Und das ist ein faszinierender Vorgang, weil das gute, der gute Teil der kooperativen Modelle, das sieht man übrigens auch bei der Programmierung des Agenten, das wird ja vielfach beschrieben, wie die noch in den 90er Jahren, als das dann begann, mit dem Netz erst kooperative Modelle, das waren ja ganz humane Menschen, also humane Vorstellungen, die man da hatte. Das wissen sie viel besser als ich, wie dieses, wir arbeiten zusammen, wir öffnen uns, alles was bis hin zu Wikipedia ja heute noch im System drin ist. Und wie dann, ohne dass ich jetzt von der Verschwörungstheorie reden würde, aber wie dann plötzlich natürlich Märkte erkannten, dass das etwas eine unglaubliche Chance für etwas ganz anderes ist und dann der egoistische Agent zum Zug kam. Es fing übrigens an bei der Telekohonikation, soweit ich weiß, wenn ich das richtig sehe, die erste richtige spieltheoretische Anwendung im Digitalen für die Verwaltung von Ressourcen war bei der Frage von Bandbreite. Wer darf rein, wer muss raus und wie verhandelt das System mit dem User?
Das war ein ganz aktuelles Problem.
Durchaus ein Problem, was da wieder auftritt.
Wir sollten vielleicht kurz sagen, wir verlinken an der Stelle Adam Curtis, All Watched Over, bei Machines of Loving Grace. Da geht es um Ayn Rand und diese ganzen schönen Utopien. Wunderbar, nehmt euch einen Tag oder zwei Zeit. Das muss man setzen lassen, so ein bisschen in einer Serie aus schönen Videos.
Die muss man wirklich sehen. Dabei finde ich halt diese Frage der Utopie, die ist ja lustigerweise am Ende wieder der Versuch, eine Utopie umzusetzen, indem man die Menschen zu ihrem Glück bringt. Also jetzt nicht zwingt, aber ihnen Incentives gibt, das Ziel zu erreichen. Also wenn man sich anguckt, wir sind dann die Leute, die halt jetzt diese Public Choice Economy erfunden haben und die sozusagen nur Steuern der Gesellschaft durch Incentives und den Versuch halt zu sagen, man versucht möglichst alles über den Markt zu regeln, indem man den Menschen, dem Markt angepasster macht, indem man ihnen dafür sorgt, dass er Überfähigkeiten verfügt, die am Markt gerade gefragt sind und dass er sich einordnet an ein Marktsystem und dabei seine Individualität nicht so sehr vermisst, weil er immer das Gefühl hat, er trifft selbst die Entscheidung, obwohl er eigentlich ja tatsächlich nur den gegebenen Rahmenbedingungen folgt. Und letzten Endes ist es ja der Versuch, sozusagen eine makro-gesellschaftliche Steuerung durchzuführen, ohne dass man die Ideologie offenbart. Also man sagt nicht gut für wen und darum geht es ja am Ende, für wen ist es dann eigentlich gut.
Das ist ja das Irre, das ist ja partiell eine totale Verplanung. Das sehen wir ja auch selber in den digitalen Szenen. Das ist ja Planung. Die Frage, die ich mir stelle, weil ich jetzt immer, wie geht es jetzt weiter, frage ich mich ja immer wieder. Also wenn wir die Geschichte haben, wie gesagt, was überzeugt uns eigentlich? Also ist es wirklich wahr, was wir alle in unserem schönen europäischen Kopf so drin haben, da kam jemand mit einer tollen Idee oder auch nicht so tollen und politischen Idee und dann die Leute werden da, wie kommt das an Menschen? Und ein Beispiel, das ja Schule gemacht hat, ist der Liberalismus und da muss man sich immer fragen, was hieß das für das 21. Jahrhundert? Also das wird die Dampfmaschine, das kennen wir alles. Der Vergleichspunkt für den Computer wahrscheinlich, die alles verändert. Diese eine Maschine verändert alles, das ganze 19. Jahrhundert bis hin zum Frage, wie die Ökonomie dann von ihr, sie verlässt dann das Bild des Blutkreislaufs und geht in den auf die Modelle der Thermodynamik und so weiter. So, jetzt fängt die an immer auseinander zu fliegen. Funktioniert nicht richtig, bringt Menschen um. Und dann kommt jemand auf die Idee und sagt, die Dampfmaschine reicht nicht. Und dann, wir brauchen ein kleines Ding, wir brauchen ein Ventil, ein Sicherheitsventil. Jetzt kommt dieses Sicherheitsventil, genannt Governor. Selbstregulierendes Ventil. Und jetzt kann man zeigen, das heißt, das wurde gezeigt, jetzt mussten Menschen nur noch darauf zeigen und sagen, siehst du, das ist Selbstregulation. So funktioniert ein System. Und das war überzeugender als jedes Buch über Liberalismus und selbstregulierendes System. Es war plötzlich, sagen wir nicht mal wie beim Automaten, beim Uhrwerk, du brauchst eine Zentraleinheit, sondern, nee, es geht auch anders. Und es gibt die sehr begründete These, dass das mir beigetragen hat zur Durchsetzung des Liberalismus, vor allen Dingen Großbritannien, als irgendetwas dieses kleine Ventil, das Governor heißt. Da kommen sich ja Fragen, warum die Menschen, die den Rettungsschirm verwalten, komischerweise Gouverneure halten, heißen und juristisch immun sind. Es sind auch sehr selbstregulierende Ventile natürlich. So reicht eine Geschichte. Und was wäre das im 21. Jahrhundert? Also was, das frag ich mich so. Das war gar nicht so bewusst. Dieses Ventil war eine Plausibilität, die war so schlagend, dass so etwas funktioniert. Und was, das ist natürlich im 21. Jahrhundert das Digitale.
Naja, gut, also das Internet. Die Ideologie, die jetzt da ja, also der mögliche Ansatz einer Ideologie, die da kommen könnte, ist ja emergentes Schwarmverhalten. Also dass es halt nicht ein selbstregulierendes System ist, sondern dass tatsächlich eine Struktur und ja, also Systeme und Mechanismen aus quasi zufälligem Verhalten von von Agenten wiederum entsteht.
Ja, doch.
Ich finde die Schlussfolgerung aber eine andere, dass du sagst, das Gesamtsystem ist schlauer als das schlauste Element. Das heißt, du wirst gar nicht mehr. Früher ist ja die Idee, du hast irgendwie vorne drei, vier schlaue Leute und der Rest muss nur folgen. Und jetzt ist die Idee, die Leute vorne müssen auch nicht schlau sein, sondern ist der Schwarm, der insgesamt Intelligenz hat.
Genau, also das halt...
Auf der einen Seite erklärt es, warum wir keine schlauen Politiker mehr haben, weil wir das in unserem Modell nicht mehr brauchen.
Auf der anderen Seite erklärt es aber, wie tief der Mist ist, in dem wir eigentlich gerade stecken. Weil der Punkt ist, dass wir... Selbst wenn wir mal annehmen...
Das ist ein Dorpens-Ding übrigens, ne?
Aber wenn wir mal annehmen, dass diese Schwarm-Ding, wo die Piraten ja auch immer viel versuchen zu argumentieren, dass das das neue zukünftige Modell ist, also dass wir da davon reden als sozusagen neues Modell von Politik, dann müssen wir aber auf jeden Fall konstatieren, dass wir dann in einer Gesellschaft sind, wo die Algorithmen, also nach denen die Schwarm-Agenten handeln und damit also die Regeln, nach denen... Die Gesetze, die Gesetze, das sind richtiges Bild. Genau, naja, das sind aber tatsächlich Algorithmen in dem Fall.
Ich weiß, es ist Gottes Law.
Dass die halt noch echt extrem unzurechen verstanden sind. Also wenn wir uns die Piraten mal angucken, also die Piraten...
Und das wird immer schlimmer, was sie dann noch machen möchten.
Verstanden und legitimiert. Sie sind ja auch nicht... Ich meine, jetzt, ich sag, müssen wir nicht mal darüber nachdenken. Das sind ja Gesetze, ich sage, es sind Gesetze, die unser Verhalten bestimmen. Die sind durch keine demokratische... Es klingt jetzt vielleicht komisch, ja, aber...
Das ist ein wichtiger Punkt. Diese Legitimierung, also wenn man jetzt sagt, okay, wenn wir, also jetzt mal nur mal nach vorne gesponnen, also wenn wir sagen, okay, wir betrachten den Schwarm als neues Modell. Also als eine Möglichkeit zu sagen, das Individuum kann sich weiter irgendwie entfalten, irgendwie seinen Dingen und Neigungen folgen. Und wenn es Lust hat, sich zu beteiligen, kann er sich doch in der Politik beteiligen und eine Art von Entscheidungsfindung. Vielleicht ist es ja irgendwie Demokratie 3.0 möglicherweise. Nur mal positive Utopie. So, dann ist aber die Frage danach, wie sind denn die Spielregeln von zum Beispiel von so einem Liquid Democracy? Oder wie sind dann eigentlich die Regeln, nach denen halt irgendwie zum Beispiel Reputationen gemanagt und verteilt wird? Wie sind denn die Regeln, nach denen ein Individuum Macht über andere bekommt oder halt einfach eine Institution bekommt? Die sind ja dann entscheidend.
Und was sagen Sie dazu? Wäre auch meine Frage an den Code-Knacker sozusagen. Wenn Eric Schmidt in seinem neuen Buch, ich nenne jetzt nur mal die zwei Sachen, das eine sagt, ja, es wird wahrscheinlich so sein, dass verifizierte Angaben im Netz, die Regierung bestätigt, ich bin, der ich bin, höher gerenkt werden im Suchergebnis als andere. Und die zweite Sache, die er sagt, neben vielen anderen, ist, das ist für die Gesetzmäßigkeit sehr wichtig, könnte sein, dass Leute, die sich dem verweigern, weil sie gerade sagten, man kann dann auch mitmachen in der Politik, die sich dem ganzen verweigern von Regierungen in hidden, ich glaube, hidden people, rassere Register geführt werden, als Leute, die besonders suspekt sind.
Das ist Propaganda aus meiner Sicht, weil der möchte gern, also ich meine, allein die Tatsache, dass es ihm da ums Suchergebnis geht, das sagt er schon alles, der möchte gerne seine eigene Geschichte da legitimieren und erzählt jetzt irgendwie, wie dort wir kooperieren. Er möchte gern den Politikern sagen, wir würden ja mit euch kooperieren und guck mal, ihr könnt ja als Input bei uns rein und dann wird es für alle besser. Das ist so das übliche Koop-Modell, was die Silicon Valley Leute fahren.
Naja, was die da eigentlich wollen, ist was anderes, nämlich, dass ihre Suge stehen bleibt und das nicht die Regierung anhaftet. Nein, nein, dass die Wahrnehmung, dessen wer mächtiger ist, sich umkehrt.
Das ist gut.
Also das halt einfach, dass es darum geht. Also ihr könnt ja doch daran mitmachen.
Deswegen sag ich Koopt. Also das ist ja eigentlich ein Begriff aus der Counterintelligence-Beidei, was die Voraussetzungen machen.
Vor allen Dingen war es ja eben mal umgekehrt. Also dass tatsächlich die Regierung gesagt hat, das sind die Spielregeln.
Und ihr könnt mitmachen?
Und ihr könnt mitmachen. Das ist sehr gut. Und jetzt sind wir an dem Punkt, wo Google und Co. sagen, das sind die Spielregeln und ihr könnt mitmachen. Und wir haben eine Legitimation dafür. Und die Legitimation dafür ist, wir sind schlauer als ihr. Weil wir haben nämlich die ganzen schlauen Leute.
Denn wir sind erfolgreich und ihr seid in der Krise. Das ist nämlich genau die Rhetorik, die wir von Silicon Valley erwarten können.
Und da kommen wir genau zu dem Punkt, warum ist denn die Politik so im Eimer? Also weil der Versuch, was du vorhin erwähnt hast, dass der Versuch, Politik zu verwissenschaftlichen, also zu sagen, wir versuchen mal politische Entscheidungen nach Fakten, nach Expertenmeinungen, nach Wissenschaft zu fällen.
Faktenbasis zu stellen.
Genau, ist sehr schief gegangen.
Und hat zum Gegenteil geführt, wir wollten eigentlich dafür sorgen, dass die Politik jetzt wissenschaftlicher wird. Und eigentlich ist die Wissenschaft jetzt politischer geworden.
Das hab ich noch gar nicht gesehen, dass das eine Adresse an die Regierung ist. Natürlich.
Ja, was zum einen damit zu tun hat, wie Politik heute funktioniert, dass nämlich also Expertise im Wesentlichen nur noch von bezahlten Lobbyisten zu bekommen ist, die wir auch im Bundestag auch immer wieder treffen. Und die können sich auch nicht vorstellen, dass wir zum Beispiel, wenn wir als CCC dahingehen, dass wir keine Lobby-Interessen vertreten, sind einfach nur zu sagen, wir wollen technische Expertise liefern. Und unser einziges Interesse ist, Wie ist denn ihr Winkel? Genau, es ist dann die Aufrichtung von Bürgerrechten. So mehr wollen wir eigentlich nicht. Und alles andere interessiert uns eigentlich auch großartig nicht. Und das können sie nicht vorstellen. Aber das führt natürlich dazu, dass halt irgendwie solche Leute wie Google und ähnlich gelassen sind, primär Google und Facebook, muss man eigentlich sagen, dass deren Ansatzpunkt mit Politik zu machen, ist ja nicht mal offensiv, so wenn man mal von so Details wie diesem Leistungsschutzrecht absieht, wo es um ihre ureigensten Interessen geht. Aber im Kern ist es ja eher so, wenn man zu diesen Google Collaboratories und wie sie da heißen, und wie man sich anguckt, wo sie so darüber diskutieren, wie könnte man denn Politik machen, was wären denn so gute Dinge und so. Das ist ja eigentlich der Versuch zu sagen, wir haben die besseren Tools. Also wir haben die besseren Werkzeuge, wir wissen mehr darüber, wir sind unideologisch und wir sind überparteilich.
Allein schon dieses wir können skalieren, ist doch die Antithese zur Regierung. Weil wir sehen immer, wenn ein Problem groß wird, scheitern die Regierungen.
Und jetzt muss man noch mal an die Planwirtschaft hängen.
Ja und jetzt kommt Google und sagt, hör mal wir können hier auf die ganze Welt skalieren.
Darf ich kurz meine, zu dem Sicherheitsventil noch mal, meine Vorschlag, der da sehr in den 50er Jahren, glaube ich, war, vor dem Advent des Computers, da hat Hayek dieses unglaubliche Buch geschrieben, dieses Papier geschrieben. Also wir hatten den Blutkreislauf, dann hatten wir die physikalischen Modelle für ökonomische Prozesse und jetzt hatte er diese Idee, das mit dem Nervensystem zu machen. Also fast eine neuronale, also Reize. Und jetzt, das beschreibt er dann richtig als Investment, Strategien von Neuronen und so weiter. Jetzt beginnen wir schon mal bei dem Wort Incentives, Anreize. Das Bild, das ich für das Sicherheitsvertreter heute fände, wäre das Netz als Nervensystem der Gesellschaft. Ich finde, der Satz, dieses Bild, das finde ich sehr trifftig, weil es ja genau das ist, die Ökonomisierung von, selbst von Bewegungen, von Wimpern, wahrscheinlich bald Wimpernschlag im Auge und so weiter. Und das ist diese Ökonomie des Geistes. Also dieses nicht mehr materielle, sondern nur noch der, sozusagen der, und das ist dann ein neues, fast Theory of Everything, weil das würde dann funktionieren, von den Reizen im zentralen Nervensystem bis in Neuronen bis hin zu der großen Kommunikation der Menschen untereinander. Ob das tragfähig ist, weiß ich nicht. Aber mir scheint, dass mir das jedenfalls einiges erklärt. Wenn ich sozusagen mich in dieser neuen Ökonomie bewege und wenn ich sehe, wie Politik reagiert, dann ist es vielmehr dieses Nervensystem-Bild, dass man uns wahrscheinlich, das halte ich für eine Ideologie natürlich, aber das jetzt kommt und das ja auch so irgendwie... Irgendwann erzeugt es dann was im Gehirn. Ein Gedanken, eine Rationalität, ein Bewusstsein, was auch immer. Aber es muss auch nicht. Es kann auch nur ein Reflex sein. Es kann auch nur ein was weiß ich Reiz sein. Und die Hirnforschung sagt jetzt auch schon selbst, die Frage des freien Willens im Gehirn ist ja noch hin. Also da sehe ich so etwas entstehen, was ich natürlich ungut finde. Ein Gesamtnerven-System, Gesellschaft ersetzt sozusagen dieses Bild des Sicherheitsventil und er bringt damit vielleicht auch eine neue Politik hervor, die mir nicht gefällt.
Vielleicht den richtigen Moment zu erklären, wie so ein unhalts Netz funktioniert. Also ich hab das vorhin kurz erwähnt, dass es ein Trend ist, dass wir das, also nicht nur ist der Code nicht legitimiert, sondern wir verstehen ihn auch nicht mehr. Und das liegt nicht daran, dass wir nicht programmieren können. Das stimmt zwar auch. Aber es liegt daran, dass so Agentensysteme und was man so hört, also das ist jetzt auch ein paar Mal Stichwort schon gefallen.
Multi-Agentensysteme.
Multi-Agentensysteme und Agentensysteme überhaupt, das ist ein Bereich aus der KI und da werden Methoden aus dem Machine Learning angewendet. Und das funktioniert grob so. Man muss sich das vorstellen wie eine Liste an Zahlen. Man reduziert sein Problem auf Eingänge und Ausgänge und schließt immer seine Eingänge an einige von den Neuronen an. Und jedes Neuron wird als eine von diesen Zahlen in der Liste modelliert. Und was man dann tut, ist, dass man die Eingänge mit den Werten bespielt, die man kennt und den Wert in jeweils dem letzten hinzugefügten Neuronen ändert, bis es das Ergebnis möglichst gut erreicht. Und wenn es nicht geht, dann macht man noch einen Neuronen dazu. Das heißt, am Ende hat man eine Liste von Zahlen, aber man kann überhaupt nicht sagen, warum der jetzt eigentlich zum Ergebnis kam. Also man kann zwar nachvollziehen, wie die Signalwege sind und man kann sehen, dass das Verfahren funktioniert, aber warum diese Zahlen da jetzt stehen müssen, dass die überhaupt stehen müssen, das kann man alles überhaupt nicht mehr nachvollziehen. Und das ist bei den ganzen Machine Learning Verfahren so. Man kann zwar inzwischen wissen wir, wie man das modellieren kann, aber das ist halt, was wir tun. Wir modellieren im Wesentlichen Evolutionen, weil wir gesehen haben, es funktioniert, aber wir verstehen am Ende nicht, was rauskommt. Das ist genau auch diese genetischen Verfahren, das ist auch so eine Sache.
Kinesische Algorithmen ja, genau.
Kinesische Algorithmen, genau. Das wendet man an bei Börsentransaktionen, um Vorhersagen zu treffen und das funktioniert prächtig, aber wir verstehen nicht, warum es funktioniert.
Wir haben eine Komplexitätsüberschreitung, also wir können halt einfach nicht mehr in einem Kopf verstehen, was...
Nee, das ist nicht konstruiert, das ist der Punkt daran. Also ein Programm ist konstruiert, wenn es nicht funktioniert.
Hat ja eine Folge einer inneren Logik, genau.
Folgt einer Logik, die kann ich verstehen und wenn irgendwas nicht funktioniert, kann ich dem Code folgen und sehen, warum hat es jetzt nicht funktioniert. Das kann ich bei Neuronen nicht machen, wenn ich sehe, das klappt irgendwie nicht, dann kann ich keins mehr rausnehmen, weil es Interconnections gibt zu allen möglichen anderen Neuronen und das geht alles kaputt. Alles, was ich tun kann, ist mehr Neuronen dazutun und irgendwann klappt auch das nicht und dann fange ich noch mal von vorne an und trainiere neu. Aber das ist alles, was ich tun kann. Es gibt kein Debugging mehr. Das heißt, wir verstehen nicht, was tut dieses Verfahren eigentlich genau? Warum tut es das? Warum kommt das Ergebnis raus? Das ist nicht mehr ein konstruiertes Ding, was ich verstehen, analysieren kann. Im Fehlerfall bin ich aufgeschmissen und das ist eine Sache, die wird eher schlimmer werden. Das ist ein Trend.
Genau das, was wir vorhin mit der Wissenschaft und der Abwechslung von Kausalitäten hin zu Korrelation gesehen haben, passiert ja genau da. Dass wir halt einen Algorithmus solange sich trainieren lassen auf der Basis der Daten, bis wir hinreichend gute Ergebnisse haben, dass unser Ziel erreicht wird.
Und alles, was du dann weißt, ist, dass das mit diesen Daten funktioniert. Der Rest ist reine Annahme.
Genau.
Wenn du da andere Daten reintust, wird das auch funktionieren. Aber das weißt du halt nicht. Im Wesentlichen kann man das vergleichen, damit ein Kind großzuziehen. Also da ist ja auch das biologische Vorbild. Du zeigst dir im Kind halt zehnmal, wenn du auf eine Herdplatte fasst, ist das heiß und tut weh. Und nimmst an, das Kind lernt es dann. Und das Kind wird auch wahrscheinlich das lernen. Aber du weißt es halt nicht sicher. Sondern es ist letztendlich Hoffnung. Und genau wie beim Kind kann man dann nicht sagen, Fehler, gehen wir nochmal zurück. Ja, sondern einmal gelernt, ist gelernt. Ich kann nur ein neues Kind machen. Und so ist das mit diesem genetischen Verschwand.
Das hat hier an dem Turing dieses Bild verwendet. Das ist wie eine Maschine zu programmieren, wie ein Kind zu erziehen.
Na, wir programmieren die Maschine eben nicht mehr, sondern wir trainieren sie. Das ist auch das Wort, das man benutzt. Das heißt, ich tu meine Daten hin, eine möglichst große Datenmenge natürlich. Das ist ja heute kein Problem mehr im Zeitallof und Big Data. Sammeln wir ja alles, was wir kriegen können an Daten. Und damit trainiere ich dann meine Maschine. Aber ich kann am Ende nicht mehr sagen, warum die Maschine jetzt eigentlich tut. Weil ich habe die Maschine nicht konstruiert, um Problem XY zu lösen, sondern ich habe sie trainiert, wie man ein Gehirn trainieren würde. Und das ist wie, wenn ich einen Arbeiter ausbilde. Alles, was ich tun kann, wenn er nicht funktioniert, ist nicht zu feuern. Ich kann ihm Anreize geben, indem ich mehr Daten raufwerfe. Aber das ist auch alles. Das heißt, dieses Verständnis nicht nur, ist das nicht legitimiert, ich kann auch nicht sagen, was es eigentlich tut. Ich kann nur prüfen, ob das Ergebnis dem entspricht, was ich haben wollte.
Das ist genau das, was mir einer dieser Wirtschaftsinformatiker sagte über die Agenten in den Pro-Frequenzmärkten.
Also das ist rein verfahrensmäßig schon bedingt.
Da könnte man dann sagen, dass es keine Überwachung geben kann. Ach, der Systeme. Man könnte also doch mit Fug und Recht oder dass man der Science-Fiction verdächtigt werden, sagen, dass die europäischen Regierungen im Augenblick, partiell zumindest, auf solche Systeme, von denen wir selber nicht mehr wissen, was sie tun, reagieren. Sofern sie im Hochfrequenzhandel immerhin 50 Prozent in den USA schon handeln und aktiv sind.
Im Allgemeinen funktioniert das ja auch bei diesem Flash-Crash. Das ist auch ein Punkt, den ich immer wieder gerne machen möchte. Da hat ja kein Computer was gemacht, was er nicht machen sollte. Sondern die haben genau das getan, wofür sie programmiert wurden. Aber die Eingaben waren halt anders.
Was sie gelernt haben, nicht mal programmiert haben.
Aber die Eingaben waren halt anders, weil eben der AP Twitter gehackt wurde.
Also ich hab mich mal angeguckt, was solche Leute irgendwie als Input für ihre Training-Algorithmen nehmen. Und die nehmen einfach alles. Also tatsächlich wirklich alles, die sie habhaft werden können. Also dadurch kommt es eben doch dazu, dass die halt tatsächlich irgendwie diesen Twitter-Feed da benutzen. Die haben teilweise so eine Twitter-Firehose gebucht, das heißt also einmal alles. Und darauf fahren die halt blind ihre Korrelationsmaschinen. Und was man dazu wissen muss, ist, was sie früher gemacht haben, war, dass sie solche Korrelationen erst mal grob gesucht haben. Also eine Vermutung hatten, da könnte es eine Korrelation geben. Und dann haben sie halt eine Engine gebaut, die nach dieser Korrelation gesucht hat in den historischen Daten. Was sie heute machen, ist, dass sie diese, es gibt also ungefähr 400, grob 400 verschiedene Korrelationsalgorithmen, um aus Daten Korrelationen abzuleiten. Also was so die bekannten Statistik tut, sind so knapp 400. Und was die jetzt machen, weil die Rechenleistung mittlerweile groß genug geworden ist, ist, dass die die einfach alle anwenden. Das heißt also, die nehmen sich halt einfach ein Set Daten. Das ist der nächste große Schritt, dass er sich halt Supercomputer hinstellt, mit genügend Speicher und genügend Rechenleistung und einfach auf einem gesamten großen Datenset nach einer Korrelation suchen. Und da weiß niemand mehr im Ansatz, wieso diese Korrelation entsteht.
Und das ist auch genauso, wie du das machen würdest, wenn du es machen müsstest.
Natürlich, klar.
Das ist ja das Schöne an dieser ganzen Sache. Wenn man sich das anguckt, das ist nicht so, dass man auf jemanden zeigen kann und sagen kann, du bist schuld, der ist schuld, der hat es jetzt falsch gemacht.
Ich glaube, und darum sollten wir von Rationalität reden. Und nicht von, das sind wir jetzt alle zu sehr nach 19. Jahrhundert. Wir müssen, das ist wirklich, vielleicht ist sogar eine zweite Aufklärung hier irgendwann nötig. Weil es eine, ja, wenn, Eric Schmidt hat mir mal gesagt, der rückt ja mit der Sprache nicht raus, aber eine Sache, weil ich jetzt sage alle Daten, weil sie sagen alle Daten, ja, hat mir mal gesagt, okay, wir werden ihnen auf die Minute sagen können, wir werden ihnen sagen können, wie das Konzert, zu dem sie heute Abend gehen, ist, bevor es begonnen hat. Und wir werden auf die Minute ihnen sagen können, wann sie von zu Hause losgehen müssen, um rechtzeitig da zu sein.
Das ist jetzt schon so, das ist ein Service, den es gibt jetzt. Der sagt einem an, fahr mal früher los, weil das gerade Stau ist.
Das ist ja auch in diesen Korrelationen. Wir wissen ja gar nicht, was solche Bewegungsdaten zum Beispiel, auch ökonomisch, also ich meine damit wieder mit dem Hinblick auf die Ökonomisierung von allem und jedem, was das wieder für ein Wert ist. Und wenn jetzt immer gesagt wird, und da kritisiere ich eben die Ökonomie, immer gesagt wird, ja das funktioniert ja nur so lange, die Menschen sind nicht so und was auch immer. Wir haben ja nun in der Lehmann-Krise gesehen, dass das ganz egal ist. Das hat Mirowski bei dem Neoliberalismus geradezu gezeigt. Auch wenn es schief geht, kann man Profit machen. Das ist ja der Punkt immer wieder. Es geht ja, wir denken immer so, jeder will jemanden wie, nein, muss nicht nur auf dem einen Weg gehen. Mirowski beschreibt das anhand der CO2-Zertifikate. Die Neoliberalen bestreiten den Klimawandel. Aber tun sie das, weil sie wirklich nicht glauben, dass es ihn gibt? Und dann zeigt er halt ganz klar, dass es immer in diesem System, immer die beiden Möglichkeiten abgewogen werden. Im Augenblick mache ich damit Profit, in zwei Stunden mache ich damit Profit und in drei Stunden mache ich damit Profit. Das Übertragen auf die soziale Wirklichkeit ist total beängstigend, insbesondere wenn man sieht, und davon glaube ich, haben wir mittlerweile erste Indizien, dass nach den Finanzmärkten die Medien und der Journalismus zu Märkten werden, die sehr stark zu automatisierten Märkten werden, die alle unterhalb ihrer Oberflächen, mittlerweile hätte ich mir nie träumen lassen, ökonomisierte Modelle haben. Natürlich machen wir uns das alle nicht so bewusst, aber letztlich ist das das. In Echtzeit oder Halbechtzeit oder über Like-It oder Twitter-Empfehlungen und so weiter, sozusagen das Pläbiscit zu sehen, die Kaufentscheidung, die der Aufmerksamkeit. Wir sehen schon, dass bestimmte Themen besonders hochgespielt werden, wenn wir diesen ökonomischen Mehrwert haben und so weiter. Und das ist nur der Anfang, weshalb ich auch besonders interessant fand, dass es gerade Journalisten sind, die mich kritisierten und sagten, das sei alles übertrieben, wo die gerade ihre eigenen Jobs zum Teil verlieren.
Also gerade die Narrative Science zum Beispiel. Für die, die es noch nicht kennen, das ist eine Firma, die machen auf der Basis von den formalisierten und quantifizierten Daten von Sportergebnissen. So gruselig. Schreiben die Sportreportagen, also von so dritter Klasse Bundesliga oder so, nicht Bundesliga, dritte Liga oder dem Äquivalent in den USA. Und zwar haben die sich halt einfach eine Million oder mehr Sportberichte aus den historischen Archiven, die mittlerweile digitalisiert sind, reingelutscht in ihre Maschinen-Learning-Systeme und haben daraus quantifiziert durch Gegenüberstellung von den Formulierungen und den Sentiments, also den Stimmungen, die da transportiert werden, mit den formalen Daten, also wie viel Ballübergaben pro Spieler, wer, wann und so weiter und so fort, dass die daraus auch extra hielen können, welche Mannschaft besonders energetisch gespielt und so weiter und so fort. Und daraus halt automatisch Sportreportagen generieren, die normalen Leser nicht mehr sehen können. Also, dass die von der Maschine geschrieben sind. Und genau dasselbe passiert auch mit Börsenberichten. Also, die schreiben tatsächlich. Bloomberg, ja. Und Unternehmensberichten. Also, diese Prospekte, die Unternehmen so alle Vierteljahre rausbringen, wie es ihnen so geht und so weiter und so fort, die werden mittlerweile auch so generiert.
Die werden nicht nur so generiert, die werden auf der anderen Seite wieder von Maschinen gelesen. Das heißt, wir sind nur noch die kleinen Modulatoren.
Der Journalismus sollte sich da mal wirklich, das verstehe ich einfach nicht. Wir sind doch nun wirklich, gerade wenn wir nicht aus den technischen Abteilungen kommen, wenn uns das jemand vor zehn Jahren gesagt hätte, dass so etwas möglich ist, dass wir jetzt schon eine hohe Trefferquote haben bei dem Problem, ob der Computer entscheidet, heißt Leit in diesem Zusammenhang Licht oder leicht, die ist jetzt bei, glaube ich, 99 Prozent. Das war so ein... Und dieses kleine Risiko nehmen wir hin. Und das ist genau das, was ich vorhin meinte. Ja, das ist immer dieses eine Risiko. Und der Journalismus in seiner ergonomischen Grundlage erlebt es gerade und erlebt es, ich glaube, man muss noch weitergehen. Das bedeutet jetzt auch der Wert von, welche Nachricht hat welchen Wert, welchen Aufmerksamkeitswert, das lässt sich jetzt messen. Und das geht sehr schnell auch in politische Ideologiebildung natürlich herein. Also natürlich, Entschuldigung, ich will nicht, ich will sagen, mir hat das jetzt ein Blogger erzählt, natürlich ist das klar, wenn Hoeneß kommt, habe ich 5.000, hat er gesagt, ja, habe ich 5.000 Leser oder so etwas. Gut, das ist Hoeneß. Aber das wird ja bald Alltag werden in jeder Beziehung. Wie wird das, die Valenz von...
Das ist jetzt schon so. Also zu dieser Firma, die haben mal so ein Beispiel veröffentlicht und dann haben sie auch den Input veröffentlicht. Und der Output hatte mehr Details als der Inputdaten hatte. Das war der Hammer, als ich es gelesen habe. Ich hab am Boden gelegen. Da standen dann so Sachen drin, wie, also das Team A hatte eine bessere, dynamischere Spiel in der ersten Halbzeit und es ging aus den Daten überhaupt nicht hervor, die hatten... Die haben die Daten daneben getan.
Ja, aber die hast du nicht in den Daten gesehen. Aber zum Beispiel, weil du halt einfach sowas wie dynamisches Spiel nicht aus Ballübergammetimings im Lesen sehen kannst.
Nein, sie haben die Daten gezeigt. Die Daten waren irgendwie so ein paar... Ballübergammetim haben sie nicht gehabt. So, das haben sie zwar irgendwie später nachgetragen, dass sie die auch haben, weil irgendwie Leute gefragt haben.
Wo haben sie denn die her, genau?
Ja, eben, aber haben sie nicht als Eingaben gehabt, sondern sie haben als Eingaben gehabt, irgendwie ein Tor in der so und so vielen Minuten. Und daraus haben sie dann generiert. Also ich will sagen, dass das Maschinen... Das ist wahrscheinlich nicht anders, wenn Menschen das machen. Das zieht ja sicher auch aus den Haaren. Aber also die Idee, dass der Kram, den wir machen, der ist nicht mehr für uns geschrieben, sondern der ist für Algorithmen geschrieben, und die das auf der Gegenseite wieder lesen. Und die Hälfte davon, die die Algorithmen rausschmeißen, der muss dann auch nicht stimmen, weil die ja nicht für uns, sondern für die Algorithmen geschrieben sind. Und deswegen ist die Hälfte auch Mist, die da drin steht.
Und was heißt das für die wirklichen Narrative, die entscheidend sind? Wir haben ja über Kahnemann schon geredet.
Alles nur noch Fake.
Nämlich die Lebensgeschichte. Was heißt das für die Lebensgeschichte? Das ist ja das allergrößte Narrativ.
Es gab neulich so ein Skandal, den muss ich noch kurz erwähnen. In England war das ein Skandal, weil da gibt es diesen Spruch, keep calm and carry on. Der ist vor ein paar Jahren entdeckt worden.
Ich hab das mit dem T-Shirt.
Und da gab es dann ein T-Shirt, da stand dann drauf, keep calm and hit her oder sowas. Also völlig sinnlos, offensichtlich frauenfeindlich, was soll das? Und da kam dann raus ein paar Tage später, dass das ein Roboter war, dieser Anbieter, der das T-Shirt angeboten hat. Der hat einfach mit einem genetischen Algorithmus 100.000 T-Shirts mit Variationen aus dem Lexikon von keep calm and irgendwas unterwandern, halt auch Anstößige dabei. Das heißt, unsere Realität besteht jetzt schon zum Teil aus computergeneriertem Unsinn, nicht nur in den Nachrichten, sondern auch, wenn wir shoppen gehen.
Sie sagen Unsinn. Das ist jetzt ja dann auch eine Frage, die sich irgendwann mal stellt. Ich will nochmal zur Lebensgeschichte. Wenn der Chef von LinkedIn, dessen Buch ich mir ja gerade angeguckt habe, The Digital You heißt das, glaube ich, der beschreibt ja, wie man jetzt in dieser Welt lebt. Und eine seiner Aussagen ist, Identität ist von gestern, wir sind liquider auch als Menschen, dieses Buch ist ja auch hochgehyped, wie sonst, sag jeden Tag ja zu deinem Tag und so weiter, aber begreife, dass ein Markt, der deine Introspektion nicht will, also deine kostbares Ich, wenn er dich nicht will, dann hast du eben auch keine Chance. Und das muss man eben weiter denken. Und das ist ja das Werden, das ist LinkedIn. Die Überzeugung des Unternehmensgründer, brauche ich keine feste Identität, brauche ich auch keine festen Arbeitsverträge, brauche ich keine Loyalität mehr. Das hat ja alles unglaubliche Konsequenzen, wenn man einmal auf diesem Spiel ist und wenn jetzt auch noch die Lebensgeschichte selber von Menschen, die sich daran gewöhnt haben, prognostisch oder retrospektiv so gelesen wird, wie ein Fußballspiel oder ein Handballspiel oder wie ein Börsenkurs, und auch das passiert ja schon, ja dann denke ich ist spätestens doch der Zeitpunkt gekommen, wo wir denen was entgegensetzen sollten.
Die interessante Frage ist ja eben, mit diesem Entgegensitzen fängt ja erst mal bei so einem relativ kulturpessimistischen Ansatz an.
Das ist aber eigentlich nicht pessimistisch.
Naja, vielleicht schon.
Realistisch.
Also wenn ich jetzt so die letzte halbe Stunde Review passieren lasse, dann kann man sich, kann man uns schon durchaus den Vorwurf des Kulturpessimismus nicht ohne Grund machen. Die Frage ist aber natürlich eigentlich dann, also was wir diagnostiziert haben, sind halt zum einen die Mechanismen unseres Denkens, nämlich dass wir uns bewusst machen müssen, dass wir mit diesem Egoismusgenerator geimpft wurden, genau wie wir irgendwie mit diesem Glauben an die Markte und die neoliberalen Mechanismen ja über Jahre uns selbst verstärkend irgendwie auch beschäftigt haben.
Ich hab das im Jahr 2000 auch toll gefunden.
Ja, sie fanden es ja auch gut.
Ich fand es gut, ich dachte, dass ich ja endlich, man kann sich das geglaubt.
So und was man danach immer hat, ist immer so ein postideologischer Kater. Also da sind wir gerade. Also dieses halt irgendwie nach der Party ist halt immer doof, weil irgendwie der Wodka war doch nicht so gut. So und genau an der Stelle sind wir jetzt gerade so. Und die interessante Frage ist ja, was könnte denn eine Utopie sein? Weil wir sind ja in der gesamtgesellschaftlichen Situation, dass der Glaube an große Utopien ist und es ist halt poststrukturalistisch zerlegt. Es gibt halt eigentlich nur noch Zynismus. Also als vorherrschende Ideologie.
Ich glaube auch, dass es völlig utopiefrei weitergehen wird. Also meine Vision ist Gamification. Haben wir noch gar nicht angesprochen.
Wir haben sie durchaus schon angesprochen, nämlich die Frage, wenn man dieser Theorie, dass es der Schwarm wird, so à la Suarez, à la Diemen, so. Na ja, es ist ja Gamification. Es ist tatsächlich Gamification. Also dass wir uns die Instrumente, also unsere digitalen Artefakte, sei es mit Glas oder was auch immer, dass wir die eben benutzen, um unser Soziotope zu gestalten. Also dass wir einfach Reputationen zum Beispiel darüber managen, dass wir Wissenstransfer darüber managen und so weiter und so fort. Aber dann, um das zu tun, und das glaube ich der wesentliche Punkt dabei, müssen wir uns darüber im Klaren sein, dass wir nicht wie einem bei einem Game hinnehmen können, dass es da einen Game Master gibt, wie dann zum Beispiel Google in dem Fall, der die Regeln bestimmt und der halt nach dem Fist of God Prinzip reagiert, sondern dass wir verstehen müssen, wie diese Regeln funktionieren. Ein Beispiel, Gamification. Ich habe gerade irgendwie Ingress durchgespielt bis Level 8.
Oh, weil ich dich gerade verbettet. Oh, schade, schade.
Ingress ist halt irgendwie so ein Augmented Reality Game von Google. Da läuft man halt irgendwie rum mit seinem Telefon. Es gibt halt in der Welt da draußen so Portale, die man hacken muss. Und es gibt halt eine gegnerische Partei. Es gibt blau und grün und so.
Also sag doch mal grob, wie das funktioniert. Du hast eine Kamera an deinem Telefon.
Nee, es ist keine Kamera. Es gibt ja erst mal ein GPS am Telefon.
Also der zeigt dir eine Map jedenfalls, wo du gerade bist.
Genau, du zeigst dir eine Map, wo du bist. Und in dieser Map gibt es halt sogenannte Portale. Und diese Portale kannst du hacken.
Die Map ist schon die reale Welt, aber die Portale sind zusätzlich da.
Und wie hackt man die?
Indem man auf einen Knopf drückt, wo Hack-Portal drauf steht. Und dann gibt es so ein Liedgeräusch und dann kommen da irgendwie Items raus. Und mit diesen Items kann man entweder Portale übernehmen, indem man sie angreift. Da gibt es dann auch die XMP-Burster, die gegen solche Portalübernahmen zerstören. Und dann kann man eigene Resonatoren ratzen. Da gibt es auch noch so eine ganze Story drinnen, die ist aber irrelevant. Aber ist schon wieder Krieg als Motivation? Nein, eben nicht. Sondern die Motivation ist tatsächlich eine... Also die Backstory ist halt, es gibt halt exotische Materie. Und diese exotische Materie ist entdeckt worden. Und die führt dazu, dass die Menschen im Schnitt schlauer werden. Jetzt kommt der interessante Punkt. Und jetzt gibt es sozusagen, gibt es halt zwei Parteien, die so den Widerstand, der meint, diese exotische Materie infiltriert unsere Gehirne und ist schädlich für uns. Und das Enlightment, was meint irgendwie, es ist gut für uns und wir werden schlauer. Und alles schlauer werden könnte die Welt retten. Die ist aber relativ...
Und auf welcher Seite sind Sie?
Ja, Enlightment natürlich.
Dessologie glaube ich wie immer.
Na klar. Also der Spitzname ist auch die Verstrahlung. Was aber der eigentlich interessante Punkt dabei ist, ist halt ein Spiel mit einer sehr hohen Immaversität. Also das heißt, man sieht die Realität tatsächlich anders. Und die Regeln, nach denen dieses Spiel funktioniert, sind komplett in dem Algorithmus. Die sind nicht expliziert. Es gibt kein Handbuch. Es gibt nichts, was dir erklärt, wie dieses Spiel funktioniert. Du hast das Programm, viel Spaß dabei. Und alles, was da an Regeln oder solchen Sachen drin ist, kommt per Software-Update. Das heißt also, du hast ein Software-Update und plötzlich funktioniert deine Welt anders. Du brauchst zum Beispiel mehr Energie, um Portale anzugreifen, oder Portale halten länger, oder du kriegst weniger Items aus den Portalen raus. Also all die Dinge, die sozusagen für dieses Spiel relevant sind, werden nicht irgendwie, jetzt haben wir mal eine Handbuchänderung, sondern da gibt es einfach ein Update, das wird zu allen gepusht und das installierst du dann. Und dann ändert sich die Welt deiner Regeln. Und was wir da haben, sozusagen so ein Vorausschau daraus, weil du eben Chemification, der sozial des sozialen Kontextes sagst, ist, wie sowas dann funktioniert. Das sind nämlich tatsächlich die Regeln, nach denen halt irgendwie wir die soziale Interaktion und die Politikgestaltung fahren, von der fucking Soft-Hilfe, wenn wir so unabhängig sind.
Ehrlich gesagt, den Punkt, finde ich einen anderen, dass du dich da hast komplett indoktrinieren lassen. Du hast einfach dein Leben umgestellt, um irgendeinem imaginärer Hunger auf Level 8 zu kommen.
Nee, das ist tatsächlich ein Experiment für mich.
Ist das ein hoher Level 8?
Das ist der höchste, ja.
Aber es war nur ein Experiment, ja, schon klar.
Nee, der Punkt ist halt, was ich halt einfach verstehen wollte, waren zwei Dinge. Zum einen, wie funktioniert es, also augmented reality gaming, im Sinne von Integration von Realität und Game. Und zum anderen, bietet das Spiel an sich keine Möglichkeiten zur Selbstorganisation, ist aber von den Incentives her so angelegt, dass du stark kooperieren musst mit anderen Spielern. So und hinthin, Google hat es halt so angelegt, dass es halt irgendwie gut integrierbar mit Google Plus ist. So, damit sie da halt mal ein paar User reinbekommen. Egal. Die interessante Frage ist halt, wie strukturieren sich halt diese Parteien? So und dann gibt es halt irgendwie zwei unterschiedliche Modelle. Die eine Partei hat halt ein eher militärisches Modell gewählt, also was halt mehr so irgendwie, sagen wir mal Star Trek angelehnt ist, wo es halt irgendwie lokale Gruppen und Hierarchien und irgendwie Ansagen und Operator und so klar gibt. Und die andere Seite hat halt mehr so ein, gucken wir mal, dann schauen wir mal, jeder macht, worauf er Lust hat, Modell für Fernseher. Wie viele Leute spielen das? Also es ist schwer zu sagen, anhand der Download-Zahlen, muss ich sagen, so eine halbe Million Leute weltweit gerade so ungefähr. Das ist halt sehr faszinierend, weil es halt einfach eine völlig neue Möglichkeiten zur Interaktion hat.
Wenn es jetzt bis level 10 ginge, würden sie auch noch weiter machen.
Möglicherweise, möglicherweise auch nicht.
Für die Wissenschaft. Also meine Vision von der Gamification ist eigentlich eher, dass du damit die Massenträge hältst und indoktriniert hältst, damit sie bloß nicht mitbestimmen wollen.
Aber sie hat noch Gamification, hat ein Element, das ja wirklich ganz entscheidend ist. Und was die, die die Preisen ja auch sehr rühmen, ist, dass sie dort dieses Leistungsprinzip tatsächlich implementiert haben. Also immer besser werden, das ist Training. Darum wird es jetzt von Krankenkassen und allen möglichen. Es ist alles ein Solar Lottery, steht ja schon drin.
Das ist doch aber auch alles nur Propaganda. Natürlich bringen die irgendwelche guten Beispiele.
Ich meine, wenn da der Gott der Gamification sagt, jetzt machen wir aus den Wahlen auch ein Game und der Gewinner kann dann mit dem Obama-Essen gehen und so weiter. Das ist alles noch auf der Stufe der Naivität. Ich finde, dass die Idee des Spiels aber man sich nicht klauen lassen sollte. Und da bin ich jetzt bei der Utopie.
Das passiert aber gerade. Ja, genau. In meines Erachtens ist das genau, was jetzt passiert.
Genau sehe ich genauso.
Ich sag mir jetzt, die nachwachsende Generation ist aufgewachsen mit Computerspielen. Die kennen das gar nicht anders, als dass ihnen das Spiel sagt, was sie gerade tun können.
Computerspiel wäre ja mir noch sozusagen so.
Nein, überlegen sie doch mal, was das für eine Sozialisierung ist.
Ich meine, dass...
Die Kinder sind doch komplett damit aufgewachsen, dass die Software ihnen sagt, was sie tun dürfen.
Aber Frank Rieger beschreibt jetzt ja schon bereits den Übergang auf die Realgesellschaft. Und das ist das Irre. Stellen Sie sich vor, ihr Leben selber wird... Ich meine, ob jetzt eine Krankenkasse aus dem Fitnessprogramm, was sie ja macht, in Amerika ein Game macht. Also dann wird genauso Incentives und es wird gemessen, ob man auf einem Home Trainer ist und was auch immer. Und wenn das immer weitergeht nach Spielregeln, die wir nicht kennen, dann wird es für mich richtig dramatisch.
Die Frage ist nicht das Kennen der Spielregeln, weil die Spielregeln, also das, was ich bei Ingers gelernt habe, ist, dass man die Regeln des Spiels, auch wenn sie einem nicht erklärt werden, sehr schnell versteht durch Erfahrungslernen. So sind diese Spiele angelegt. Aber das Interessante daran ist, es gibt niemand, dem man da zur Verantwortung ziehen könnte oder mit dem man reden könnte, weil natürlich wird dieses Spiel genauso betrieben, wie eBay seine Callcenter betreibt. Da gibt es nämlich kein Callcenter. Da gibt es halt irgendeine E-Mail-Adresse, wo man irgendwie eine Mail hinschicken kann und dann bekommt man als gnadenerweisende Antwort. Vielleicht, wenn die Frage irgendwie passte oder es irgendwie interessant war. Und dann gibt es halt irgendwie so einen Community-Manager, der sich halt in so einer Google-Plus-Gruppe rumdrückt und extrem selektiv auf die Fragen antwortet. Und auf die Fragen, die Leute wirklich auf den Nägeln brennen, wird halt nicht geantwortet, weil sie die vielleicht nicht beantworten können, nicht beantworten wollen, was auch immer. So und genau dieses Prinzip, dass es halt so einen Game Master gibt, der halt die Regeln setzt und tatsächlich irgendwie quasi der Gott in diesem Spiel ist. So, genau dieses Prinzip gilt es eben zu durchbrechen. Und genau das ist ja auch das Ding, woran die Piraten ja gerade scheitern, ist ja, dass sie eben in ihrem Liquid-Democracy-Game irgendwie sich nicht darüber einigen können, wie sie booten. Also nämlich, wie sie halt die Spielregeln, also die initialen Spielregeln von denen aus dann weitere Spielregeln verändert abgeleitet werden können, demokratisch zustande kriegen. Daran scheitern die ja gerade.
Es gibt aber auch Spiele, in denen sich die Spielregeln ständig neu konstituieren durch soziale Interaktion. Das ist ja das, was Gesellschaften bisher war. Ich bin natürlich jetzt traurig, dass sie dieses Spiel bis zur achten Stufe durchgespielt haben. Das spricht sehr dafür, dass es selbst am grünen Holze schon beginnt, Googles Weltenplan.
Na gut, ich meine, also ich hab's halt nur...
Ihr hättet sich jederzeit aufnehmen können.
Nein, das sag ich nicht. Nein, das ist nicht wahr. Würde ich tatsächlich nicht behaupten. Ich hab's nur halt mit einem Account durchgespielt, der nicht auf mich zeigt, also der sonst nicht.
Sie sollen ja auch nicht identifiziert werden, sondern sie wollen sie sozialisieren.
Man braucht es ja nicht, dass die Leute einen Account haben, der auf dich zeigt, das spielt doch überhaupt keine Rolle mehr. Es gibt doch da Talks bei Google drüber. Die müssen überhaupt nicht wissen, wer du bist. Das interessiert die gar nicht. Die müssen nur dich wiedererkennen können, damit sie dir Werbung zeigen können, der Reste ist scheißegal.
Gerade beim Abschweifen sind eines der Dinge, wo sie richtig auf die Schnauze geflogen sind, mit diesem Spiel, war der Versuch, da Werbung einzubauen. In diesem Spiel gibt es sogenannte Passcodes. Die gibt man ein, sind einfach nur mirose Character. Dann bekommt man so Items und Punkte und so. Also es ist nur so einfach so ein Goodie. Und die verteilen die da halt auch. Und dann kam jemand auf die gleiche Idee, wie man halt Werbung in diesem Spiel machen kann.
Und da gibt es halt ein Like Samsung oder was?
Nein, nein, ist ja Google, also nicht ganz so doof. Sondern sie haben die Nummernschilder von einer kalifornischen Carsharing-Bude als Passcodes freigeschaltet. Und haben sich offenbar vorher nicht darüber informiert, wie diese Carsharing-Bude ihre Autos akquiriert. Nämlich immer Blockweise. Das heißt also, wenn du ein Passcode hattest, also ein Nummernschild, dann musstest du nur einfach tausenderweise hocheterrieren und hast du halt irgendwie da endlos halt irgendwie abräumen können. Seitdem sind sie so ein bisschen vorsichtig mit dem Einsatz von Marketing in diesem Spiel.
Also ich finde ja den zentralen Punkt an der Stelle, dass unsere Kinder das gewöhnt sind, dass Software in den Regeln vorgibt. Daher dieses ganze Gerede von wegen, wir müssen den Game Master wegkriegen. Die Frage wird sich nicht stellen, weil die Generationen einfach das nicht so wahrnehmen.
Nee, bloß aber das ist doch unsere Aufgabe, dafür zu sorgen, dass die Methoden, das ist natürlich unsere Aufgabe, dafür zu sorgen, dass die Methoden, nach denen die Regeln in digitalen Gesellschafts-Spielen, anders kann man es nicht mehr nennen, wie z.B. Liquid Democracy und ähnlichen Versuchen, dass die demokratisch gebootstrapped werden, damit man von da aus demokratisch weitermachen kann. Also dass die Veränderung von den Regeln wiederum nicht von einem Game Master kommt, sondern eben tatsächlich aus der Gesellschaft.
Da gibt es übrigens ein Beispiel für, nämlich EVE Online, die haben das tatsächlich so gemacht. Deren Vorbild war ein Markt, es ist so ein Sci-Fi-Weltraum, blablabla. Aber da gibt es tatsächlich Wahlen im Spiel auch. Und die Entscheidungen werden ansonsten den Spielern immer lassen. Es gibt so ein paar Mindestgarantien, wenn du dich in Kernsektoren aufhältst, da gibt es dann irgendwie Polizei. Aber so die ganzen Sachen, wenn du irgendwie Ressourcen meinen willst von Asteroiden, das ist halt weiter draußen. Und da kannst du dann auch Pirat werden und andere Spieler. Und das kannst du nicht nur werden, sondern das ist so...
Das ist so rein Design zu sein.
Die scheinen ja aber auch ganz schön.
Nein, ich spiele das nicht, aber ich habe mich mit einem unterhalten, der mir das anspatzen wollte. Der meinte, das ist toll, da hat man totale Freiheit. Das war eine von diesen libertären Amerikanern. Aber der Punkt ist, wenn man diese Demokratie und Freiheit einführt, wird das natürlich sofort missbraucht. Weil wenn es ein Spiel ist, die Leute diese Schranke zur Realität nicht sehen. Da ist nämlich plötzlich Verhalten okay, was man in der Realität nie tun würde.
Also jetzt sind Sie ja der Kulturpessimist, auch in Sachen der Kinder und so. Aber mein Blickpunkt wäre ein anderer. Ich habe beobachtet, dass gerade im Umkreis der Piraten, die es ja immer noch gibt und die ich ja auch gar nicht abschreiben würde, aber diese Sätze, die wir dauernd lesen, wie blöd die Politik ist, was diese neuen Systeme angeht, das ist eine totale Unterschätzung. Vielleicht im Augenblick noch. Aber all das, was Sie gerade beschreiben, also mein Problem ist gar nicht so sehr die Kinder. Da können wir noch was wie im Spiel dann... Sondern das sind nur noch Millisekunden, bevor politische Systeme, Institutionen reproduzieren sich permanent in allem, die Chancen von so etwas für sich selber erkennen. Also wenn das erstmal verschmilzt mit politischer Wirklichkeit, wenn Gamification und all diese Incentive-Modelle, die dahinterstecken, sozusagen Politik werden, zusammen mit diesem Konsumidee der Politik, dass Politik selber nur ein Konsumgut ist, dann wird es ernst. Ich glaube, es führt zu nichts. Das wäre jetzt meine Intervention. Das hat ja auch niemand gesagt, aber es wird oft gedacht, ja die Politiker und auch übrigens die Medien, es wird natürlich mächtige Medien in der Welt weiterhin geben, sind einfach so blöd, die moderne Welt. Nein, die werden sie. Irgendwann kommen die und dann werden sie sie verstanden haben. Und darum, da bin ich jetzt aber ganz bei Ihnen auf die Frage der Utopie. Wie es genau geht, weiß ich auch nicht. Ich nenne hier immer wieder den Namen Gigarenzer. Das ist ja das, womit sie sich auch bei der Robotik beschäftigen. Eines wissen wir, und das ist doch auch toll, ganz viele Ressourcen, die wir früher dafür brauchten, uns viele Gedanken über irgendwas zu machen, die brauchen wir jetzt nicht mehr, weil das können die schon gut, die Systeme. Jetzt sind die frei. Und jetzt müsste man, glaube ich, kapieren, und das wäre fast so, wir haben ein Hesse-Glasperlenspiel, vielleicht kein gutes Beispiel, aber erklärt das ein bisschen, wohin wir investieren müssten. Und das wären Dinge, die wir für selbstverständlich halten. Intuitive Elemente, kreative, alles das, was mit Unberechenbarkeit natürlich zu tun hat. Also eigentlich alles das, was nicht Maschine ist. Das wäre von der Bildung bis zur Anerkennung im Beruf und so weiter. Das wäre so etwas, was eine Utopie wäre. Einer Gesellschaft, so wurde sie sich ja auch ursprünglich mal gedacht. Auch das muss man sich jetzt nicht so maximal vorstellen. Aber es gibt schon Vorschläge, wie man zum Beispiel im Unterricht damit, wie man Intuition, die man nur durch Menschen lernen kann, weil diese Systeme sind so stark und so mächtig, dass man nicht glauben kann, dass jetzt eine altbackene Politik sie nicht kapiert, sondern sobald sie irgendeinen Effekt für die haben, wird sie die kapiert. Und wer weiß, ob das dann noch die Parteien und die Politiker sind, die wir heute haben. Das wissen wir ja auch nicht, wie das in 10 oder 15 Jahren aussieht. Darum finde ich, sollte die Energie genau in dieses, was nicht, also das Spiel wieder zurückerobern, raus aus diesen Systemen in das Lebensspiel, das wir selber spielen und das wir als Wesen mit künstlerischen, kreativen und intuitiven Energien spielen. Und das ist dann auch nicht mehr Markt. Das ist übrigens auch so was, dass jetzt auch das Spiel total ökonomisiert wird. Das ist die im Foreign Affairs, ja es war schon immer so, aber das müssen sie mal lesen. Das ist ja nur ein Auszug, aber die sagen, das ist super Gamification. Das bringt endlich, es sagen die so nicht jetzt mit Darwinismus, aber es bringt endlich die Überlebensstrategie, die wir sonst so gar nicht mehr in der Gesellschaft, also Überlebenskampf, kann man ja nicht mal sagen, bringt das sozusagen zurück auf eine spielerische Weise in die Gesellschaft. Erinnert mich an den Atari-Chef, der in den 90er-Jahren zu den Kriegssimulationen, da weiß man ja, das sind ja auch nicht viele Leute, dass die Computerspielhersteller zum Pentagon gerufen wurden.
Um die Simulator zu bauen.
Genau, bauen sie die für uns. Und der sagte dann mal in einem Interview, diese Kinder spielen nicht, diese Kinder trainieren fürs Leben.
Die Frage ist auch, wenn wir schon bei Utopien sind, wie man die Menschen bewertet. Wenn man sagt, nach der Leistung, und jetzt kommen immer Maschinen, die das einfach besser machen als wir, weil die nicht schlafen müssen, dann haben wir ganz schnell eine zweite Klasse Menschen, die einfach weniger wert sind als die Maschinen.
Ist jemand, der viele Twitter-Follower hat, dann vielleicht viel wert? Heute wahrscheinlich schon.
Na gut, ich meine, die Bewertung hängt ja momentan...
In ihrer eigenen Selbstbewertung vielleicht.
Moment, ich meine, momentan hängt ja tatsächlich der Wert...
Also für den Personalchef meine ich jetzt.
Also die Wertzumessung im ökonomischen Sinne ist ja immer abhängig von der sozialen Interaktion, also von dem, was andere ihm zumessen. Aber die interessante Frage ist eben tatsächlich, sobald halt irgendwie die Bewertung maschinell erfolgt, also man tatsächlich Scores und Indizes hat, verbreitet sich ja der Bewertungsmaßstab automatisch sehr viel breiter, der von sehr wenigen Menschen, nämlich den Programmierern, oder denen die Programmierer gesagt haben, wie so ein Score computed wird, tatsächlich vorgeschrieben wird. Also bei Social Media gibt es ja irgendwie so Cloud und noch ein paar andere von diesen Services, die halt irgendwie versuchen, die sozusagen in eine Maßzahl, die soziale Einflussreichweite zu kristallisieren und die dann zu vermarkten an Leute, die halt irgendwie sagen, okay, wir wollen halt mit den Multiplikatoren reden, ist irgendwie Social Media Bullshit, das muss man nicht weiter diskutieren. Aber die interessante Frage dabei ist halt eben, wenn wir sagen, okay, wir werden nicht umhin kommen, soziale Werkzeuge zu digitalisieren und auch die Kommunikation in der Gesellschaft möglicherweise zu gamifizieren, was vielleicht von alleine passiert oder weil halt irgendwie solche, was weiß ich, die fünfte Iteration von Liquid Democracy dann doch funktioniert, dann heißt es aber eben auch, das ist ein wichtiger Punkt, eben nicht nur die Spielregeln, nach denen Kommunikation und Entscheidungsfindung funktioniert, algorithmisch sind, sondern eben auch die Reputation.
Ja, und darauf will ich hinaus, denn das heißt, Gamification ist nichts anderes als ein Börsenspiel. Das ist nämlich ein anderes Spiel als das Spiel, das ist ein Spiel, wo dann tatsächlich evaluiert wird und wo das ganze Leben zum Börsenspiel wird.
Ich muss hier noch einen Puls bauen.
Also nicht zwingend. Wenn tatsächlich diese Ideologie, die dahinter steht momentan, die halt also den Markt als Maß aller Dinge betrachtet, auch der Ideengeber für diese Gamification und diese sozialen Werkzeuge wird, dann haben wir nichts gewonnen, dann geht es genau so weiter wie bisher. Dann wird das eben selber zur Börse. Genau, sondern die Herausforderung besteht ja eben darin, tatsächlich sich dafür Regeln auszudenken und eben genau dieses Schwarmverhalten.
Spricht aber im Augenblick alles für das andere. Auch die Volatilität von Leben mittlerweile, von Lebensläufen, von Berufen, die Volatilität von Menschen, die eben noch eine Ausbildung hinter sich gebracht haben und jetzt schon den zehnten Arbeitsvertrag mit irgendwas anderem. Das spricht ja eher alles für das Gegenteil.
Ich will Ihnen noch eine Vision kurz mit Ihnen teilen. Ich spiele gerne Computerspiele, deswegen betrifft mich diese Gaming-Vacation-Sache.
Welche?
Ach, verschiedene, aber eins, was ich eine Weile gespielt habe... Nein, ich sage hier keine Namen, das wäre Werbung. Eins, was ich eine Weile gespielt habe, da gab es wöchentlich Updates und da wurden dann immer so Zahlen verschoben. Diese Pistole hat dann zehn Punkte mehr Schaden gemacht als letzte Woche und dann... Oder es dauert länger, bis sich da der Schuss löst.
Krieg ich nach Tetris.
Na ja, das sind jetzt natürlich alles irgendwelche Ballerspiele. Aber den Punkt, den ich dann machen will, das ist genau die Art von Änderungen, die ich vorhin beschrieben habe, die man bei Neuronalnetzen macht. Also das heißt, was wir haben an der Stelle ist, wenn man die Perspektive ein bisschen dreht, dass wir jetzt schon die Spielregeln nicht mehr so machen, dass die ein Programmierer macht, sondern das ist ein genetisches Verfahren, was im Schluss, den ich vorhin schon getroffen hab, keiner versteht. Das hat nämlich kein Mensch mehr konstruiert, sondern da wird hier ein bisschen und da ein bisschen. Und am Ende, man macht das so lange, bis es funktioniert.
Und die Frage ist, was es dann heißt, dann funktioniert da. Das heißt, ist es die mehr Playtime?
Je nach der Bewertung, die man halt einspielt, populär wahrscheinlich.
Genau, mehr Playtime oder mehr...
Und weniger Leute, die rumheulen.
Genau, also sozusagen einfach nur Anzahl der Messages auf der Support-Q versus irgendwie Playtime, eine hoch, eine runter und dann spielt man so lange mit dem neuronalen Netzwerk in den Parametern rum, bis es passiert.
Genau, und jetzt stellt euch mal die Zukunft vor.
Was tun wir als Parameter in unser politisches Neuronals-Netzwerk für die Öffentlichkeit?
Stell dir mal vor, du hast überhaupt ein neuronales Netzwerk, was dein Leben bestimmt plötzlich. Und nicht nur ist es nicht legitimiert, sondern du weißt auch nicht, was es tut. Du kannst nur beobachten.
Da muss man sich zumindest mal darüber unterhalten, was die Optimierungsparameter dafür sind. Also was das Optimierungsziel des neuronalen Netzwerks wäre. Womit er wieder bei der politischen Vision wäre.
Aber überleg dir mal, was es für dich heißt, wenn du von Sachen kontrolliert wirst, von denen du weißt, dass niemand versteht, wie es dazu gekommen ist.
Danni Suarez hat mir ja gesagt, ich hab ihn ja irgendwie interviewt zu seinen Büchern, und eines der Dinge, die er mir gesagt hat, war, als ich ihn fragte, was er denn rausgestrichen hat, hat er gesagt, naja, er hatte halt einen Kapitel drinne, wo der Demon Leute totgespielt hat, weil sie in einer Endlosschleife gelandet sind. Also weil der Demon sagt ja den Leuten, was sie tun sollen, er gibt ihnen ihre Missionsziele so und er hatte ursprünglich einen Kapitel drinne, was er dann zu komplex fand, deswegen rausgenommen hat, wo tatsächlich ein Software-Bug den Leuten Missionen setzt, die sie nicht erfüllen können und wo sie quasi in einer Endlosschleife hängen. Also immer wieder von einer Mission in die andere geschickt werden, ohne dass sie da wieder rauskommen können.
Ich fand das sowieso viel zu optimistisch, das Buch.
Die Endlosschleife wäre, um jetzt noch mal abschließend auf die Spieltheorie zu kommen, tatsächlich zu Ende gedacht, das Prinzip, wenn ich denke, dass er denkt, dass ich denke und er weiß, dass ich denke, dass und so weiter. Das ist die Endlosschleife.
Die dann am Ende darauf hinausläuft, wer mehr Arbeitsspeicher hat.
Nee, wer mehr CPU-Zeit hat für seine Noreinandernetze.
Arbeitsspeicher am Ende.
Aber aus den Zeiten sind wir, den Zahn musst du jetzt hier ausziehen, aus den Zeiten, wo der Arbeitsspeicher das Limitphasen wieder raus.
Nicht für, wenn du große Mengen Daten analysieren willst.
Sie erinnern sich, Sie waren dabei, Eric Schmidt, der doch erzählte in Berlin, ich habe die gute Nachricht, wir werden noch vor dem Jahr, ich glaube 2020, einen Speicher haben für unter 1000 Dollar, der in der Lage ist, wenn sie an einer Videokamera angeschlossen ist, 400 Jahre ununterbrochen aufzuzeichnen. Und dann sagt er...
Ich sollte mir an Black Mirror, das ist ein Magazin, verlinken. Das ist so eine britische Serie, die sich genau mit solchen Fragen beschäftigt.
Black Mirror ist tatsächlich irgendwie ein schlechter Launermacher.
Oh ja, aber das sind Fragen, die gestellt werden müssen.
Na gut.
Ja, jetzt haben wir allen nachdrücklich schlechte Laune gemacht.
Wir entschuldigen uns für die schlechte Laune. Vielleicht gab es ja auch ein paar positive Inspirationen. Also wie gesagt, ich finde es genau die Idee, halt einfach zu versuchen, über die Regeln politischen Zusammenlebens als Algorithmen nachzudenken und uns nicht damit abzufinden, dass es da Game Master gibt, ganz wichtig.
Und es nicht irgendwelchen unverstehbaren Verfahren zu übergeben.
Ja, und vor allen Dingen sich dabei eben nicht von solchen Ideologien wie halt dem Egoismus leiten zu lassen, die uns eingeredet wurden.
Und nicht von der Effizienz. Das ist übrigens eine der hartesten Waffen, die Silicon Valley hat. Optimierung, das geht hier um die Effizienz, das ist besser, wenn wir das so machen.
Nutzenoptimierung, aber zu sagen nicht von einem Speedmaster ist natürlich, was passiert, das ist doch der Punkt, wenn die für uns das Handeln übernehmen. Niemals größer im Ausmaß. Und Egoisten sind.
Das ist doch dieselbe Frage, die wir seit Beginn der Menschheit haben. Wollen wir, das beste Verfahren, sagt man ja immer, wäre der wohlwollende Diktator, der alles richtig macht.
Ich find das gut, jetzt sind wir bei dem Anfang der Menschheit. Das ist doch ein gutes Ende.
So ist das mit dem Game Master. Das will man ja auch haben. Man hat einen Game Master, der in Notfallssachen reparieren kann, aber der ist wohlwollend und würde das nie missbrauchen. Aber wenn wir so jemanden haben, dann brauchen wir auch keine Gamification. Dann können wir auch direkt den zum Kaiser enden.
Das ist diese Mittelalter. Entweder ist der liebe Gott lieb, dann ist er aber schwach, oder er ist böse und dann ist er ziemlich böse.
Na gut, dann sind wir am Ende. Vielen Dank Herr Schirrmacher.
Danke schön.
Vielen Dank fürs Zuhören.
Und nehmt euch mal ein Wochenende Zeit, um so eine Ruhe zu verdauen.
Genau, und die Links irgendwie durchzuklicken, die wir dazu tun werden. Ansonsten, falls ihr Lust habt, da gibt es daneben noch einen Flatter-Button, wo ihr gerne draufklicken könnt. Ansonsten machen wir mal keine Versprechungen über die Frequenz unserer nächsten Sendung, aber wir versuchen mal einfach unser Bestes. Dann vielen Dank fürs Zuhören und bis zum nächsten Mal.